SO THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN MERGING
SEA AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WAS SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY ALTHOUGH
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING TODAY HERE
. THIS IS WHAT I JUST SAID HERE
YES OKAY SO THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PERFECT PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO MEET ON MUTE
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR I. T. PERSON
I WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE. THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY
TO ADDRESS THAT COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I'M GOING
TO ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN SIX TWO. TWO FOUR SIX
TWO AGAIN THE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO SIX SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO I WILL ANNOUNCE THIS
INFORMATION AGAIN BEFORE PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES STEM WORKS
PLEASE ONCE AGAIN GO TO THE
SENATE OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME
AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AND AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST NEED
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS ìED.
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED. LASTLY FOR
EVERYONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE
TODAY PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASKS ON
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE
COPYRIGHT SENATOR NIELSEN THE
SENATOR ON YOUR- THANK YOU THE
CONSOLE NORD'S NOTES THAT A
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING ALL THE
ISSUES LIST AND THE DISCUSSION
SECTION OF THE AGENDA. AFTER
DISCUSSION WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ALL OF THE ITEMS
AFTER PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
HOLD A VOTE ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ITEMS ONE THROUGH
THIRTY TWO. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE DISCUSSION ITEMS WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY AND
ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY THREE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME'S JUSTIN
HOW'RE AND DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
FISCAL POLICY ADMINISTRATION FOR
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY AND
THE FIRST I AM BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS RELATED TO OUR GOVERNMENT
EXPLAINS THE TRANSMISSION CENTER
SPECIFICALLY. IS REQUESTING FOR
POSITIONS. FIVE THOUSAND NINE G.
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE AND ONGOING THE
STAFF ARE GET CENTER WHICH IS
WHAT IT'S KNOWN AS AN WHICH WILL
ALLOW US TO ACCELERATE THE
MODERNIZATION STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER DOES THIS BY PARTNERING
WITH STATE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT
INNOVATIVE PILOT THAT COULD BE
SCALED ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT
OR BROAD ADOPTION. ADDITIONALLY
TO GET CENTER WILL ESTABLISH A
REPOSITORY OF BREAST PRACTICES
AND CASE STUDIES OF SUCCESSFUL
OPERATIONAL INNOVATIONS THAT
MEASURE BILLION GROUP THE
STATE'S OPERATIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS WITH ME TODAY IS
TO WERE DROWNED OUR DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR INNOVATION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. RELATED TO THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. THE STORE WERE YOU
GONNA SAY SOMETHING- MANAGER
KNOW THAT YOU FOR GIVING THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO- TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE GET CENTER IT'S
BEEN WERE HAVING AND ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE OKAY
GOTCHA OKAY FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY COMMENT. AND
WEBER BUT THE FINANCE. WE HAVE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME BUT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OKAY L. A. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMON. BUT I'M SURE
JONES- LA- WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
DISPOSAL. OKAY OKAY WE WILL NOW
OPEN THE DISCUSSION TO QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY VICE CHAIR
. SENATOR RON OKAY AND- ALL
RIGHT WELL WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON THEN I FEEL LIKE WE COULD BE
ON A ROLL TO ISSUE NUMBER WELL I
HAVE A QUESTION- DOES GOD DOES
DEVOPS ALREADY HAVE DEPARTMENTS
DEPARTMENT PROJECTS AND PILOTS
PLANNED FOR THE GET CENTER. NO
CHAIR WE ARE WAITING FOR OF THE
FLOW OF PROPOSALS THAT WILL COME
IN- FROM OUR FRIENDS.
TRANSFERRING STATE OPERATIONS
INITIATIVE THAT IS WRAPPING UP
ITS WORK THIS SPRING AS WELL AS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA LEADS-
INITIATIVE THAT HAS GONE TO- HOW
HR SO WE EXPECT WE'VE WE'VE
GOTTEN SOME INNOVATIONS OFWHAT
KIND OF. THINGS ARE LOOKING AT
AND WHICH OF THAT- SET OF-
PROPOSALS WILL BE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE GET CENTER WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF- PILOTS THAT WE'VE
DONE AND WE HAVE ONE UNDERWAY.
BUT YOU DO HAVE A SELECTION
PROCESS AND OUR CRITERIA- YES
OKAY. OKAY BECAUSE THE CHECK IN
SOMETIMES IT'S GOOD TO BE ON THE
RECORD. THANK YOU SO NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER UP THERE
NIELSEN. THESE PROJECTS WILL THE
LEGISLATURE HAVE ANY OPPORTUNITY
TO INPUT- REVIEW THESE PROJECTS
IN ADVANCE. WELL WILL- WE'RE
ALWAYS INTERESTED IN HEARING
INPUT FROM THE LEGISLATURE-
THERE IS GOING TO BE A PRETTY
RIGOROUS. EVALUATION THE PROCESS
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO SHARE THAT
PROCESS WITH YOU. WELL I WOULD
REQUEST THAT THAT WE WOULD HAVE
THEM. EACH ITEM THAT WE GET A
CHANCE TO REVIEW. THE
LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE TO HAVE
SOME AUTHORITY TO REVIEW THINGS
THAT ARE GOING ON OUT THERE.
KEEP THAT IN MIND I'M GOING TO
BE WATCHING OVER THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR WORKLOAD ADJUSTMENTS
. BRITNEY'S MANAGER JUSTIN HARD
AGAIN FOR GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY- I AM THIRTY FOUR IS
RELATED TO THAT WORKLOAD WITHIN
OUR AGENCY SPECIFICALLY WE'RE
REQUESTED TO POSITIONS AND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND I'M GOING TO FIND IN MANAGE
EXISTING WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE OVERSIGHT MANAGEMENT OF
THE OPERATIONS. WELL WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO IS TO GET
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO HELP
SUPPORT AND PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
FARMERS AGENCY SERVICES
FUNCTIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED
UNDER THE STATE'S EMERGENCY PLAN
AS WELL AS TO PROVIDE POLICY
DEVELOPMENT AND STATEWIDE HIM
CLICK ON PRIVACY POLICIES FOR
OUR AGENTS AND OUR REPORTING
DEPARTMENTS. WITH ME TODAY IS
GOING ON A GIRL SHE IS THE
STATE'S CHIEF DATA OFFICER AND
EITHER HER OR I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU HAVE RELATED TO
THIS PROPOSAL. OKAY THANK YOU
MAY HOW NO. I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM. NINE ONE ONE IF I. BEGIN
WITH NO COMMENT AT THIS BUT TO
AND ANY YOU HAVE ON US ALL THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THE L. A. O.'S
OFFICE. HELLO HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED WITH THE WORK OF BOTH
. OKAY GREAT TO OPEN IT UP
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. MISTER
VICE CHAIR. THE OKAY I HAVE A
QUESTION. THIS SIZE STATEWIDE
PRIVACY OFFICER WHAT'S THE ROLE
OF THAT PERSON. AND WHAT DOES
PRIVACY ENTAIL BECAUSE- THAT IS
A LOADED WORD IT COULD MEAN A
LOT OF THINGS. EMILY JOY
WHENEVER OF THE STATE'S CHIEF
DATA OFFICER GIVE RESPONSES IT'S
A VERY GOOD QUESTION. YES THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE- YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. I THINK YEAH. YOU HAVE
AREA MISTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION AND- THAT I
THINK THE PRIVACY- ACTUALLY
MEANS LOTS OF THINGS SO LOTS OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE BUT I THINK AT
ISSUE ARE THE KEY QUESTIONS-
PRIVACY OFFICERS HAVE TO ADDRESS
IS- WHAT IS THE PROPER LEVEL OF
DATA COLLECTION- ON THAT USAGE
AND MANAGEMENT BECAUSE
ULTIMATELY ON PRIVACY IS AROUND.
RIGHT IN THE- IN YOUR DATA AND
HOW YOUR DATA IS MANAGED BY
OTHERS AND SO IT'S REALLY HOW DO
WE ENSURE ACROSS THE STATE NOT
ONLY THE STATE HAS EXCELLENT
POLICIES AROUND PRIVACY- BUT HOW
DO WE- YOU POTENTIALLY. ENSURE
CONSISTENCY BETTER SURE
PRACTICES ACROSS GROUPS- ALL
ALIGNMENT WITH ALSO THE GREATER
NEED TO ADD ON TO IT USE OUR
DATA NOT ONLY WITH GREATER
PRIVACY BUT MORE EFFECTIVELY AND
SO HAVING A CENTRAL PERSON WHO
CAN ADDRESS PRIVACY QUESTIONS-
RECONCILE YOU KNOW CONFUSION
AROUND ON THE APPLICATION OF
PRIVACY LAW AS YOU AS I'M SURE
YOU KNOW. AND THAT NOT ONLY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES ON THERE ARE
MANY MANY MANY LAWS ON AND
REGULATIONS GOVERNING ON THE USE
OF THE PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
DATA- ACROSS MANY SECTORS IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN WHETHER IT'S
FINANCIAL DATA HEALTH DATA- FEEL
. YOU ALTHOUGH ALL THOSE KIND OF
DATA ABOUT HOW AND HOMELESSNESS
SERVICES AND SO HAVING ON A
CENTRAL PLACE TO CALM FOR
CONSISTENT GUIDANCE ACROSS THE
STATE- WILL REALLY HELP FURTHER
ON THE STATE'S. ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THE
PRIVACY OF OUR RIGHTS AND- SO IS
THIS ABOUT HAVING A REPOSITORY
FOR ALL OF THIS DATA. OR IS IT
ABOUT HAVING- PROVIDING-
GUIDANCE TO HOW DATA IS
COLLECTED ACROSS ALL AGENCIES
WITHIN THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
DEFINITELY THE LATTER RIGHT SAID
THIS IS AN- THIS IS HOWEVER
YOUNG YES WHEN WE COLLECT DATA
HOW DO WE DO THAT IN A WAY THAT
IS ON YOU KNOW CONSISTENT WITH
ALL OF OUR PRIVACY PRACTICES AND
PRINCIPLES WHAT IS SHARED
GUIDANCE THAT WE CAN DEVELOP
AROUND THAT THAT CAN BE
STATEWIDE SO THERE'S JUST LAST
USER CLAIMING THE LEVEL. THE
LATTER OF- ON YOU AND HEARING TO
THE STATE'S EXISTING VERY STRONG
AND POWERFUL POLICIES AND SO. ON
IT'S ABOUT THAT CONSISTENT
FRAMEWORK AND GUIDANCE AS WELL
AS- A GO TO PLACE FOR EMERGING
OR NEW PRIVACY ISSUES THAT MIGHT
COME UP IN THE CONTEXT THAT
DEPARTMENTS ARE FAKE. RIGHT OKAY
USUALLY PEOPLE ARE COMING YOU
ARE OFTEN COMING TO ME FOR THAT
GUIDANCE AND THAT'S NOT REALLY
APPROPRIATE I DON'T HAVE THE
FULL EXPERTISE FOR THAT AND SO
HAVING SOMEONE WHO CAN BE
FOCUSED ON THOSE ISSUES. IN
DEVELOPING CONSISTENT GUIDANCE
AND BEING CONSISTENTLY AVAILABLE
ACROSS THE STATE IT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR HERE.
YEAH MANAGER IF I COULD JUST ADD
THIS IS AN AREA WITHIN OUR
AGENCY WHAT WE NEED TO DEVELOP
THIS EXPERTISE WE OVERSEE QUITE
A FEW STATE ENTITIES WHO HAVE A
LOT OF. LOCAL INFORMATION
RANGING TAX. FROM THE- RATING TO
HUMAN RESOURCE AND FROM. FOR
STATE EMPLOYEE. PENSION
INFORMATION NOT ENGINE SYSTEMS.
SO AND WE ALSO OVERSEE THE
CONTROL AGENCY DEPARTMENTS. ALEC
DDG ASTON CD T. WHO ALL HAVE
HUGE ROLES ARE COMMON EIGHTY-
REQUIREMENTS AT ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS. AT THE PLACE TO
LOOK AT AGENCY HERE WE CURRENTLY
DO NOT HAVE THAT EXPERTISE AND
WE PLAN ON. HIRING FOR THIS
POSITION TO DEVELOP THAT
INTERNALLY SO WE CAN HELP
PROVIDE THAT GUIDANCE AND
OVERSIGHT FROM. OUR LEVEL HERE
AND YOU CAN. OKAY GREAT THANK
YOU- SO NO OTHER QUESTIONS WERE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE WHICH IS THE CHIEF
EQUITY OFFICER. AND ON. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO START WITH THAT-
HI MANAGER JUSTIN HARD AGAIN IT
CUT OFF. FOR YOU IS THAT TRAILER
BILL PROPOSAL THAT WILL ACTUALLY
FORMALLY. THE SHE EQUITY OFFICER
IN. AS WELL AS PROVIDE SOME.
FRAMEWORK FOR WHAT THAT
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THIS
INDIVIDUAL WITH PETE I'M IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET RECEIVE FUNDING
AND APPROVAL FOR THIS POSITION
HOWEVER THE TRAILER BILL WAS NOT
AND APPROVED ULTIMATELY AS PART
OF THE BUDGET SO THEREFORE WE
WHAT WE'RE REQUESTING IS TO
FORMALLY HAVE ESTABLISHED
STATUTES AS AN APPOINTEE OF THE
GOVERNOR- SO THAT WE CAN THEN
MOVE FORWARD WITH. THE EFFORTS-
AGENCIES EVEN DIVERSITY IN.
THROUGHOUT STATE OPERATION.
HAPPY AND ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
RELATED TO THE THANK YOU SO
BEFORE I DO THAT I'M I DO WANT
TO JUST SAY THAT WE'RE GONNA
LEAVE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
OPEN AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
LEAVING ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
OPEN AND NOW WE ARE ON ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY FIVE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER AND FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COMMENT. AND WEBER
DEVELOPING A FINANCE NO COMMENTS
ON THE SIDE OF ME THERE BUT
AGAIN HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. A GREAT THANK YOU L.
A. O.'S OFFICE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COMMENT. ALAMO AERO SIMILARLY NO
COMMENTS ON THIS BILL. OKAY
GREAT VICE CHAIR. WELL IS THIS
NOW FORMALLY STATUTORILY CREATED
OR IS THIS ANTICIPATED TO BE
CREATED. THIS WOULD BE FORM SIX
BALLOTS FORMALLY ESTABLISHED IN
STATUTE THE POSITION AS AN
APPOINTEE OF THE GOVERNOR AS
WELL AS DEFINING.
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL BE WORKING ON BUT
THAT DIDN'T HAS NOT PASSED YET
HAVE NOT PASSED YET THAT IS
CORRECT LAST YEAR WE DID RECEIVE
FUNDING IN POSITION OF AUTHORITY
BUT WE DID NOT RECEIVE THE
AUTHORITY- IN STATUTE IN TERMS
OF KIND OF PUTTING TOGETHER AT
THE- FRAMEWORK WHAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL BE WORKING ON A LEGAL
DEFENSE AND- CRITICAL TO. THE
BATTING STATUTE ARE WE GONNA GET
IN THE HABIT NOW AND GOVERNMENT
OF- PUTTING BUDGET STUFF THE END
BUT. WE DON'T EVEN HAVE A
STATUTE TO. FROM THAT OF. THIS
IS A LITTLE BIT UNUSUAL AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED I'VE BEEN
AROUND THIS PLACE TO DON LONG
TIME. AND AS FAR AS STATUTORY
AUTHORITY FOR ESTABLISHING. THE
THAT IS NECESSARY TO GO THROUGH
THE BILL PROCESS- WE RECEIVED
FUNDING BUT WE DID NOT RECEIVE
THAT STATUTORY AUTHORITY OR THE
UP TWENTY FEET LAST YEAR THAT'S
ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR WE KIND OF
VIEWED AS THE TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
TO LAST YEAR'S. I NEED APPROVAL
. WELL I THINK I SEE A LITTLE
MORE GRACIOUSLY THAN THAT SIR
I'M NOT GONNA LOOK FAVORABLY ON
THIS. LET IT GO OKAY SENATOR RON
. OKAY ARM I ACTUALLY WOULD HAVE
A QUESTION WHICH IS HOW MANY-
OUTCOMES OR GOALS BEEN DEFINED
FOR THIS PARTICULAR OPPOSITION.
NOW ADD TO DATE HAS NOT AND WE
HAVE THE YOU TO DO THE STATE ARE
ALREADY TO GO TO. ROOF FOR THIS
POSITION- BUT ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT THIS DECISION WILL
DO IT'S KIND OF THAT PROCESS. I
NEED- SOME GOALS AND- CORRUPTS
STATE ON. RELATED TO LACK
DILUTION AND DIVERSITY AND
THEY'LL BE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR CONTROL AGENCY DEPARTMENTS
ON THAT EFFORT. THIS ITEM OPEN
AND THEN MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SIX. WHICH IS FREE
RELIEF FOR NEW BUSINESSES. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TOMORROW JOHNSON HERE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I WILL BE
PRESENTING AT THIS A PROPOSAL TO
YOU TODAY. AT THE BUDGET
INCLUDES THIRTY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
WAY FIRST TIME FILING FEES FOR
NEW BUSINESSES REGISTERING WITH
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
FROM JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THROUGH JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY CARDS
FURTHER BUSINESS GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA THE WAY FILING FEES
ARE FOR CORPORATIONS LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES AND LIMITED
PARTNERSHIPS. I REQUEST ALSO
INCLUDES BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WITH WHICH SPECIFIES THAT
FUNDING MUST BE SPENT ON THE
WAVING OF THOSE SPECIFIC FEES
THAT THE AMOUNT COULD
POTENTIALLY BE INCREASED IF MORE
BUSINESSES THAN ANTICIPATED FILE
AND THAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CHAU REPORTS ON THE FINAL AMOUNT
OF BILLS WAIVED FEES WE'D LIKE
TO NOTE THAT WE'VE REVIEWED THE
L. A. O.'S COMMENTS ON THIS
PROPOSAL. AND AS THEY POINTED
OUT ALL THE FILING FEE AMOUNTS
ARE RELATIVELY SMALL WE STILL
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS
MERIT- THERE AY BE CALIFORNIANS
THAT HVE THOUGHT ABOUT CREATING
A BUSINESS BUT HAVEN'T DONE SO
YET AND THIS PROPOSAL COULD BE
THE ENCOURAGEMENT THEY NEED TO
TAKE THE FIRST STEP IN
SUBMITTING THE NECESSARY
DOCUMENTATION AND STARTING THAT
BUSINESS FORMATION PROCESS. IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES THAT THIS IS THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT BUSINESSES
IN CALIFORNIA AND THIS FUNDING
IS PROJECTED TO POSITIVELY
IMPACT THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES I
JOINING ME TODAY IS BETSY BOGARD
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE AND WE'RE BOTH HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU THANK YOU. SO NOW
WE WILL HEAR FROM FINANCE. YOU
MEAN THE L. A. L. MAN YES I'M
SORRY- THIS IS NICK SCHROEDER
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- AS THE AGENDA INDICATES
AND HAS THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
INDICATED- WE DO HAVE A COMMENTS
ON THIS PROPOSAL AND- WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
REJECT THE PROPOSAL. ON THE
GROUNDS THAT IT WON'T
MEANINGFULLY- LEAD TO AN
INCREASE IN OUR NEW BUSINESSES
ON THE TREND HAS BEEN THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN GROWING NUMBERS OF NEW
BUSINESSES FILING- WITHOUT
REDUCTION AND IN LIGHT OF THESE
COSTS THE TAKES. THE START UP A
NEW BUSINESS- IN CALIFORNIA THE-
THE SMALL SIZE OF THE P. REALLY
IT WOULD NOT BE THE THING THAT
PREVENTS PEOPLE FROM- THE
OPENING OF A BUSINESS STATE. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO
RECOMMEND THOSE THAT IF YOU DO
ADOPT THE PROPOSAL- WE RECOMMEND
MODIFYING THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE THAT IS MORE SPECIFIC
AND SO THAT IS MY MORE EXPLICIT
AS FAR AS WHICH- FEES ARE BEING
WAIVED FOR THE FISCAL YEAR- AND
THE LAST PIECE THAT WE RECOMMEND
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE. DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION TO REVIEW THE
FUND ITSELF BECAUSE- IT. WE THAT
THE CURRENTLY PAID BY BUSINESS.
NEW BUSINESS ANNEX THIS. ARE
HIGHER THAN THEY NEED TO BE
ASSISTING ON- THAT BEING SAID
THE BUSINESS CONNECT- SYSTEM IS
IN ITS LAST MODULE HI AND- IT
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE. THE
SECRETARY STATES OPERATIONS AND
BECAUSE OF THAT THEY MIGHT NOT
KNOW WHAT THE APPROPRIATE FEW
LEVEL OR- RESERVE LEVELS ARE FOR
AT LEAST A COUPLE OF YEARS SO WE
THINK. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
EVENTUALLY SHOULD DIRECT- THE
MINISTRATION REPORT ON WHAT THE
- ROBERT IF YOU STRUCK SHOULD BE
AS WELL AS RESERVE WOMAN. OKAY
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW OPEN IT UP
FOR DISCUSSION AND QUESTIONS
FROM OUR- COMMITTEE I SEE
SENATOR ROTH HAS HIS HAND UP.
OKAY VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU A
THANK YOU MISTER BOETTCHER THANK
YOU VENTURE I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COMMON IN THE AGENDA OF THE
TALKS ABOUT. AND SUGGESTED
BUSINESS IS ENTITIES HAVE BEEN
PAYING HIGHER FEES AND NECESSARY
TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM. GIVEN
THE TRANSFERS TO THE GENERAL
FUND IN THE- ASSISTANCE THIS IS
TIED TO THE RESERVE LIMIT OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS I GUESS WHY NOT
INCREASE THE RESERVE LIMIT AND
REDUCE. THE BUSINESS FEES
CHARGED TO BUSINESSES AT THIS
POINT IN TIME AND THEN ADJUST AS
NECESSARY ON AN ANNUAL BASIS AS
WE MOVE TO THROUGH THIS
PARTICULAR MODULE TO WHATEVER
FOLLOWS. ANY TAKERS. SURE I CAN
AGO FIRSTHAND DON'T. I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS IS THAT WE
UNDERSTAND SHOOT THIS FUND IS
SUPPOSED TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT
AND SO YOU WANT TO BE CAREFUL IN
ESTABLISHING THE FUNDS THE
STRUCTURE AND- THE RESERVE
LIMITS TO ENSURE THEY CAN'T
REMAIN TO BE SELF SUFFICIENT I
THINK THAT CONSIDERING THE
BUSINESS CONNECTION IS GOING TO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE HOW THE
DIVISION OPERATES. IT MIGHT
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE WHAT
RESOURCES SECTOR STATE NEEDS-
AND WHAT FEW LEVELS MIGHT BE
REQUIRED AND SO THAT IS WHY WE
RECOMMEND THAT IT BE A DECISION
IS MADE LATER THAT BEING SAID IF
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS THAT THEY
CAN DEVELOP SOONER THAN THAT- IT
DID IT WOULD NOT BE A BAD IDEA.
BUT THAT'S WEIRD WE DEAL WITH
SPECIAL FUNDS AND SPECIAL FUND
INSOLVENCY ALL THE TIME IN OUR
BUDGET WOULD THIS NOT BE DEALT
WITH BY INCREASING THE SIZE OF
THE RESERVE IF WE CAN'T PREDICT.
THE EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BUSINESS CONNECT OPERATION
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF THE
RESERVE TO COVER ANTICIPATED.
COSTS REDUCE THE- OVER. WARM
REDUCED FEES CHARGED TO
BUSINESS. AND THEN FURTHER IT
JUST AS BUSINESS CONNECT COMES
ONLINE AND NUMBER ONE QUESTION
NUMBER TWO. THIS IS STATE
GOVERNMENT CERTAINLY WE DON'T
ENTER INTO PRO OF PROJECTS
BUSINESS CONNECT OR OTHERWISE.
WITHOUT HAVING A BUSINESS PLAN
AND DOING PROJECTIONS AS TO
REVENUE AND EXPENSES CORRECT.
SERA THIS IS BETTY BOGAERT WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE I AM THE- CHIEF
OF THE BUSINESS PROGRAM DIVISION
A CO SPONSOR FOR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS CONNECT. WE ARE EXCITED
TO REPORT THAT THE BUSINESS
CONNECT FINAL MODULE FOR
BUSINESS ENTITY FEATURES IS
GOING INTO- GOING TO BE LAUNCHED
AT THE END OF THIS MONTH MARCH
TWENTY NINE- AND IT WILL PROVIDE
FOR ONLINE SERVICES FOR-
CORPORATIONS RELIABILITY
COMPANIES AND LIMITED
PARTNERSHIPS. WE DO HAVE-
REVENUE PROJECTIONS AND
EXPENDITURES AS YOU MENTIONED-
THE CHALLENGE HAS BEEN THAT IN
THE PAST WE HAVE UTILIZED HAND
TALLIES- TO HELP THE NUMBER OF
ENTITIES THAT WE HAVE RECEIVED.
AND SO WE WERE HOPING TO HAVE AT
LEAST A YEAR OF STABILITY TO
DETERMINE- WHAT CLASSIFICATIONS
WE NEED IN ORDER TO- BEST SERVE
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO. TO- THE
MAKE SURE THAT HAVE. SUFFICIENT
MEANS THE BASE ARTS CURRY
CHARGED. CORPORATIONS IS A
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO- FOR THE
INITIAL FILING AND LIMITED
LIABILITY COMPANIES LIMITED
PARTNERSHIPS ARE SEVENTY DOLLARS
SO THOSE TREES- WE FEEL OUR ARE
REASONABLE- V. WE CERTAINLY ARE
IN FAVOR OF RAISING THE MILLION
DOLLAR THRESHOLD OR WITHHOLD
AMOUNT- THAT WILL WILL BETTER
SUPPORT- ARE. PROJECTIONS SO AT
ANY TIME THAT ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO DO THAT WE WOULD NOT BE
OPPOSED TO THAT- BUT AT THIS
POINT WE WOULD WE WOULD PREFER
TO WAIT ON ADJUSTING FEES UNTIL
WE COULD PRESENT AN ENTIRE PLAN-
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
WELL I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
APPROPRIATE ACTION. ALTHOUGH I'M
JUST JUMPING BACK INTO THIS.
BUDGET BUSINESS AFTER A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME SO I MAY HAVE LOST
THE BUBBLE BUT SEEMS TO ME THE
APPROPRIATE POSITION WOULD BE TO
RETAIN THE MONEY TO INCREASE THE
RESERVE LIMIT TO. BUILD THE
RESERVES IF THERE'S UNCERTAINTY
AS TO THE EXPENSE LEVEL
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BUSINESS
CONNECT- MODEL AND THEN AS THE
RESERVES BUILD IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT YOU. ARE YOU HAVE A
SUFFICIENT RESERVE TO DEAL WITH
CONTINGENCIES THEN START
REDUCING THE FEES TO BUSINESS OR
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO SPEND THE
MONEY THAT BENEFITS THE
BUSINESSES THAT YOU SERVICE. AS
OPPOSED TO THE GENERAL FUND.
THOSE ARE MY ONLY COMMENT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE AND THE
GREAT WORK THAT YOU ALL PROVIDE.
PERFORMING PROVIDE FOR ALL OF US
OVER THERE EVERY DAY THANK YOU A
MANAGER. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
. YOU'RE GOING TO NEED TO
CONVINCE ME THAT THIS IS MORE
THAN JUST SYMBOLIC IT IS SO
MINIMAL. AND THE FILINGS HAVE
GROWN CONSIDERABLY HELLO THAT
WOULD NOT APPEAR TO INDICATE ANY
DETERRENT FROM THE CURRENT
LEVELS OF THE FEES- SO WE'RE
GOING TO. MAYBE THIS SOUNDS CUTE
BUT WHAT EVIDENCE DO YOU HAVE TO
SAY THAT THIS THIS IS GOING TO
BE SIGNIFICANT DO YOU HAVE ANY
DATA ANY NUMBERS OF A
PROJECTIONS OF HOW MANY
BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO REALLY
PROSPER BY THIS IS GOING TO TURN
OF BUSINESSES AROUND MY GOSH IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE DO
MOST OF OUR THINGS HARM
BUSINESSES LARGE AND SMALL. TELL
ME WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT SO
SIGNIFICANT. TELL ME HOW MUCH
MORE THAN SYMBOLIC. RIGHT TO MY
PER CAPITA FINANCE I GO BACK TO
OUR OUR AT OUR PRIOR COMMENT
THAT WE DO THINK THERE COULD BE
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT HAS NOT
OCCURRED TO BUSINESS BUT NEVER
SHE TOOK THAT STEP AND HELP THEM
BUT AND I'D ALSO POINT OUT IN
TERMS OF WHAT YOU SAID PATRICK.
I WE DID INCLUDE BUDGET
WILLINGLY FOR THAT REASON WHERE-
SIGGERS THEY'LL BE- REPORTING ON
. THE EXACT KIND OF WAVE. OF
WILL BE ABLE TO SEE IN THE-
ENTRANCE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
AS TO WHAT THAT WE WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN AND WE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN. AND
WE HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JASON FOR
COUNTING KEEP HER PERMISSION
AFTER FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS I AM
INTRODUCING TO BCPS THAT REQUEST
FUNDING TO SUPPORT SOFTWARE
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS FOR TO
MISSION CRITICAL IT SYSTEMS.
FIRST THE BCP FOR THE BRIEF
SYSTEM MAINTENANCE AND CREDIT
CARD FUNDING REQUEST TWELVE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
ONGOING. THE PROJECT BASED
INCLUDED IN JANUARY TWENTY
SIXTEEN I HAVE BEEN IN A
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS
BASED. SENSE FENCE POST SINCE
THEN SUPPORTING THE DAILY
BUSINESS NEED. A PROGRAM. YES
THE MODIFICATION ARE SUPPORTED
ENTIRELY BY STATE I. T. STAFF.
THIS FUNDING WILL COVER COST
CENTERS INCLUDING FUNDING FOR
STATE I CAN STAFF SALARIES AND
BENEFITS TRAINING FOR STAFF
DEVELOPMENT SOFTWARE AND
HARDWARE FONG. THE FUNDING
REQUESTED IN THIS B. C. P. FOR
FREE SUPPORT REPRESENT THE
BASELINE COSTS THE DEPARTMENT
REQUIRES JUST FOR NORMAL
MAINTENANCE OPERATIONS MOVING
FORWARD. OF THE TWELVE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS REQUESTED
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION ROUGHLY
HALF OF THE A THIRD OF THE
REQUEST WILL BE ALLOCATED TO PAY
FOR PROCESSING FEES ON BEHALF OF
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES WHO PAY
ONLINE USING A CREDIT CARD. THE
SECOND BCP REQUEST ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT THE FIRST
FULL YEAR OF MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS FOR THE CONNECT
SYSTEM. WHICH IS UTILIZED BY
FORTY CA PROGRAM. EJECTA DELIVER
FIVE MAJOR SOFTWARE RELEASES
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY THAT ALLOW
THE FORTY CA PROGRAMS LICENSEES
AND APPLICANTS. TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS ONLINE REMEDIATE
ANY APPLICATION DEFICIENCIES AND
RECEIVE EMAIL AND TEXT MESSAGE
ALERTS RELEVANT TO THEIR PENDING
APPLICATION OR LICENSE STATUS.
THE SYSTEM ALSO ALLOWS FOR THE
SUBMISSION AND PROCESSING OF
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS AMONG OTHER
FEATURES. ROGIC IS SCHEDULED TO
COMPLETE IN LATE APRIL BUT
BECAUSE OF THE INCREMENTAL
APPROACH DELIVERY SYSTEM
FUNCTIONALITY THE FOUR PROGRAMS
INCLUDED IN THE PROJECT HAVE
ALREADY SEEN OUR- OF THE SYSTEM
. IS THE FIRST MAJOR SOFTWARE
RELEASE IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR PROGRAM TO PROCESS
OVER TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONLINE TRANSACTIONS. AND OVER
90% OF THE OVERALL PAYMENTS MADE
I'VE BEEN ONLINE VIA CREDIT CARD
TRANSACTION. I WOULD LIKE TO
ALSO MENTION THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS AWARE OF THE L. A. WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD MAKE
SOME DEPARTMENT PROPOSAL
CONTINGENT UPON THE INCREASES.
THE DEPARTMENT BELIEVE THIS
LANGUAGE COULD CREATE LOGISTICAL
FINDING ISSUES THAT COULD IMPACT
CONSUMER PROTECTION AS SEVERAL
OF THE PROPOSALS. ARE TO
CONTINUE FUNDING FOR EXISTING
RESOURCES. THESE RESOURCES
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR IT'S ANY FEE
INCREASE LEGISLATION WOULD NOT
BE FINALIZED UNTIL LATE TWENTY
TWENTY Q. AND NOT EFFECTIVE
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. IT WOULD CAUSE A
GAP IN AUTHORIZED RESOURCES FOR
THE BOARD IN EUROPE. ESSENTIALLY
HALTING PROGRAMMATIC ACTIVITIES
IN THOSE AREAS. THE DEPARTMENT
LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MANY STAFF TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION THAT WORK TOWARDS A
SOLUTION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THESE TWO
REQUESTS. I'M JOINED TODAY BY
JOHN O'CONNOR CAN TAILOR SHIFT
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU SO
NOW WE WILL HEAR FROM FINANCE.
CHARLIE MANNING THE OF. WHERE IS
OF DC I'D PROPOSALS PRESENTED
TODAY WHICH CONTINUES THE
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS OF
BREEZE THE STAFF OF SUPPORT IT
I'M GOING SOFTWARE AND DATA
COSTS AS WELL AS MAINTENANCE
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION COHORT
ONE SOFTWARE ALTERNATIVE. ALSO
IN RESPONSE TO THE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THAT WE WOULD AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS DCA HAS MADE ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL CHALLENGES OF THE
SUGGESTED PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
AS IT WOULD DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
OF RECENTLY PASSED LEGISLATION
AND THE CONTINUATION OF EXISTING
OPERATIONS AND IT PROJECTS AND
ESPECIALLY DELAY FUNDING TO
PROGRAMS THAT PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND SUPPORT LICENSEES IN THE
STATE. UNTIL SHE INCREASE IS
APPROVED IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
THANK YOU. BUT THE ALEJO AND WAS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS AND
THERE'S NOTHING IN THEM THAT.
ARE WE HAVE WE TAKEN ISSUE WITH
A RAISE ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS
ABOUT THE AS HAS BEEN NOTED BY
DCA AS WELL AS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE DO POINT OUT THAT
THERE ARE SOME. FUND INSOLVENCY
ISSUES WITH SOME OF THE DCA
FINDS- THREE OF WHICH ARE
RELATED TO THE PREVIOUS AND
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
PROPOSALS- THESE FUNDS THAT HAVE
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCES AND ARE
PROJECTED TO BECOME INSOLVENT OR
GO INTO A DEFICIT WITHIN THE
NEXT TWO TO THREE YEARS. I'M
SPECIFICALLY THIS INCLUDES THE
CONTINGENT FUND BOB THE MEDICAL
BOARD WHICH HAS SPENDING THROUGH
THE BREEZE PROPOSAL. THE PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
ADMINISTRATION FINE AND THE
STATE BOARD OF CHIROPRACTIC
EXAMINERS FIND- BOTH OF WHICH
ARE RECEIVING A FUNDING-
PROPOSED RECEIVE FUNDING UNDER
THE BUSINESS MODERNIZATION. SOFT
ON THE MINISTRATION IS PLANNING
TO SEE FEE INCREASES FOR THE
POLICY PROCESS IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AS IS COMMON
PRACTICE- HOWEVER THIS APPROACH
DISCONNECTS ME ON THE HEALTH OF
THE FIND AND RESOLVING
INSOLVENCY ISSUE SOME FROM THE
FIND- I'M AWAY FROM THE
PROPOSALS TO INCREASE
EXPENDITURES OUT OF THESE. THAT
ARE ALREADY PROTECTED TO GO
INSOLVENT I'M TO THE EXTENT THAT
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVES
EXPENDITURES FROM THE FINDS OUT
WE RECOMMEND ADOPTING
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO MAKE
SURE THERE'S SUFFICIENT FUNDING
IN THE RESPECTIVE FINDS. I'M
SPECIFICALLY BY ASSOCIATING THE
FUNDING BILL MAKING FUNDING
AVAILABLE ONLY IF LEGISLATION IS
ENACTED TO INCREASE THE SPEED
AND WE FELT WOULD HELP. I'M TIED
THE INSOLVENCY ISSUE AFTER FIND
TO THE EXPENDITURE PROPOSALS TO
ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT
APPROVING ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURES OUT OF FUNDS I
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SUPPORT. IT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. I
THINK YOU- I WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE RECORD THAT'S SENATOR COME.
IS NOT PRESENT NIELSEN VICE
CHAIR YOU HAVE ANY. WELL I JUST
WITH A THAT THE- AT RE. SEEM TO
GET THIS BACK AND CON THAT YOU.
HAVE UNINSURED OF YOUR FUNDING.
BEFORE YOU'RE MOVING A. AT THE
RESIDENCE ME THAT WE'RE STARTING
TO GET IN THE HABIT OF DOING
THAT. AND SO I WOULD. WOULD A
CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT THE RELIGION
YESTERDAY AS PROCEED. THANK YOU
FOR THAT ROB. THE MANAGER OF. AS
THE PARTICIPANTS KNOW I
TYPICALLY SEE THESE ISSUES ONCE
AGAIN AND ANOTHER SIDE OF WHAT
WE DO HERE ON THE POLICY SIDE
AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH FUND IN
SONG OF SOLVENCY AND PROPOSED
FEE INCREASES WHICH ARE NOT.
EASY SUBJECTS TO DEAL WITH AND
IT'S- IN LARGE PART BECAUSE
WE'VE- I HAVE CREATED OUR OWN
PROBLEM IN THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION CONSUMER AFFAIRS AREA
WE- DECIDE FOR PURPOSES OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION THAT WE NEED
TO SET UP AN ARCHITECTURE. WHERE
WE ESTABLISH BOARDS AND BUREAUS
AND WE'VE DONE THAT FOR ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE OR THIRTY SIX OF
THEM AS I RECALL. AND WE SET UP
A PROCESS BY WHICH WE LICENSE
PEOPLE. REQUIRE THAT THEY HAVE
CERTAIN SKILLS AND EDUCATION AND
TRAINING BUT ONCE AGAIN FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION. AND TO FIND
THIS A SYSTEM THAT WE SET UP
ACROSS THESE VARIOUS BOARDS AND
BUREAUS WHICH ARE STAFFED BY.
STATE EMPLOYEES THE STATE WAGE
AND BENEFIT SCHEDULE AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH GOVERNMENT WHICH ALL
CARRIES A PRICE TAG. WE SET
LICENSE FEES. AND IN PART THOSE
LICENSE FEES PAID BY THOSE
LICENSEES OR TO ENSURE THAT THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE LICENSED IN THOSE TO
DONATE HERE. TO THE STANDARDS OF
CONDUCT OR THE STANDARDS OF
PRACTICE OR ARE DISCIPLINED AND
LICENSES ARE ADJUSTED. BUT THEN
AS GOVERNMENT TYPICALLY DOES AND
I'M NOT A CRITIC OF GOVERNMENT
BUT GOVERNMENT HAS A COST WE HAD
SYSTEMS AND PROCESS. WE APPROVE
MO USE. IN THIS CASE WE HAVE
COMPUTER SYSTEMS WHICH GET
EXPENSIVE. AND THEN BECAUSE THIS
DCA BOARD IN BUREAU PROCESS
WHICH MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY KNOWS MUCH BETTER
THAN I DO TO HER PRAYER LIFE-
CARRIES A COST AND IT'S THIS IS
FUNDED SOLELY BY THE LICENSEES
WE THEN TURN AROUND AND WE ARE
FORCED TO INCREASE LICENSE FEES
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE FUND INSOLVENCY
BECAUSE BY AND I. T. PROJECT AND
OTHER THINGS. THAT THEN RESULT
IN A PRESSURE TO INCREASE THE
LICENSE FEES PAID BY LICENSEES.
THAT SEEMS TO ME TO BE A
COMPLETELY BIZARRE AND
UNWORKABLE AND UNSUSTAINABLE.
SYSTEM AND I KNOW WE'RE NOT HERE
TO DISCUSS THAT TODAY EXCEPT IT
IS PART OF THIS AND I'M JUST
TALKING TO THE ADMINISTRATION AT
THIS POINT AT SOME POINT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO SIT DOWN AT THE
TABLE. AND DECIDE WHAT AMOUNT OF
MONEY LICENSE THE LICENSEE
SHOULD PAY THROUGH THEIR LICENSE
FEES AND WHAT IT SHOULD BE USED
FOR AND RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER PARTS OF THIS THAT ARE
PART OF STATE GOVERNMENT THAT
ARE UNRELATED UNRELATED TO WHAT
THE LICENSEES ARE DOING WITH
THEIR LICENSES. THAT OUGHT TO BE
FUNDED APPROPRIATELY BY THE
GENERAL FUND. SO I'VE NOW GIVEN
MY LECTURE FOR THE DAY AND I
WILL STOP TALKING BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO AT SOME POINT HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH SOMEONE. ON
THE WAY WE'VE STRUCTURED THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
AND THE WAY WE'VE STRUCTURED
THIS LICENSE AND LICENSE FEE
PROCESS. AND WHAT THE LICENSE
FEES ARE USED FOR BECAUSE-
HAVING LOOKED AT THIS NOW FOR
TWO YEARS IT'S NOT WORKING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
TOLERATING NO NO I MEAN DOES
ANYONE WOULD. YOU CARE TO
COMMENT OR RESPOND TO THAT
MAYBE- TO DCA. THANK. THAT'S
OKAY I WOULDN'T EITHER IF IT WAS
A RHETORICAL QUESTION TO THE
EXTENT IT WAS EVEN A QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU WE'D LIKE TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR THE COMIC THE
MAJESTIC OF THE MAKE THE
PROPOSAL AND THIS IS KIMBERLY
HARBISON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENT
SENATOR ROTH AND WE ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN HAVING A
CONVERSATION THAT WILL FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU. THANKS CABALLERO. WELL
I THINK THAT SENATOR ROCKET ON
AN ON AN ISSUE THAT THAT IS-
THAT IS PROBLEMATIC IN THAT
DESERVE SOME SOME DISCUSSION AND
IF HE'S GOING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION I LIKE TO BE A
PART OF THAT HAVING- SAT IN THE
SECRETARY CHAIR- WITH THE CA
AND- AND HAVING INTIMATE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE BREACH
PROGRAM- AB I UNDERSTAND
COMPLETELY WHAT THE- WHAT THE
ISSUES ARE AND- AND- THE
DECISION WAS TO BUY A BIG. I. T.
PROGRAM AND- HAVE EVERYBODY PUT
IN A LITTLE PIECE. OF IT IS AND-
BUT IT ALSO INVOLVES CHANGE
MANAGEMENT WHICH IS ALWAYS A
HARD THING. FOR DEPARTMENTS AND
FOR BOARDS TO DO. AND- SO. THAT
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH ALL I HAVE TO
ADD TO THAT. OKAY THANK YOU WILL
MAKE. AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT
CONSUMER PRIVACY IMPLEMENTATION
AND ENFORCEMENT. AND WE'RE READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHERYL HOW MODERN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ASH HOUSEHOLDS HAUNTING. I'M
A NONEXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NEWLY ESTABLISHED CALIFORNIA
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS WITH.
POTASSIC ADMINISTERED. AND
ENFORCEMENT OF THE NATION'S
FIRST COMPREHENSIVE CONSUMER
PRIVACY LAW THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT. THIS IS
OUR FIRST TIME FINALISTS
COMMITTEE I THOUGHT I PROVIDE A
BIT MORE BACKGROUND ABOUT THIS
ISSUE HERE AND THIS WAS HERE.
OUR AGENCY WAS CREATED AFTER
VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION
TWENTY FOUR CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
RIGHTS ACT TWENTY TWENTY TO.
TWENTY TWENTY. WHICH REMAINS
EXTENT COMPETITION THE PRIVACY
ACT OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
GRANTS CONSUMERS THE RIGHTS TO.
LIMIT AND CONTROL BUSINESS THIS
COLLECTION AND SHARING OF
PERSONAL NEXT. CTRP COMPANY
CONSUMERS BY IMPOSING. ON
CERTAIN CALIFORNIA BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY THOSE THAT HAVE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OR MORE IN GROSS
REVENUES SELL OR SHARE PERSONAL
INFORMATION OF ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR MORE COMPANY
CONSUMERS FOR THOSE THAT DERIVE
15% OR MORE OF THEIR ANNUAL
REVENUE SELLING AND SHARING OF
CONSUMERS PERSONAL CONNECTION.
POSTOCULAR PROGRAMS APPROPRIATES
LEADS THANK GENERAL FUND FIVE
MILLION OR TWENTY TWENTY ONE. OR
202-022-2020 ONE AND TEN MILLION
PER FISCAL YEAR THEREAFTER.
BURKE SENATORS TO SUPPORT THE
OPERATION OF THE AGENTS. IT'S
OPERATIONS CAN BE BROKEN DOWN
INTO THREE KEY AREAS. RULEMAKING
TO ADOPT AMEND AND RESCIND
REGULATIONS THAT IMPLEMENT SIXTY
PF. ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATIVE OR ENFORCEMENT OF
THIS YEAR WHICH BEGINS IN JULY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. AND
PROMOTING PUBLIC AWARENESS AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE RISK POOLS
AND RESPONSIBILITIES SAFEGUARDS
AND RIGHTS IN RELATION TO THE
COLLECTION USE AND SALE OF
PERSONAL INFORMATION. DURING ITS
FIRST SIX MONTHS AND WITH THE
SATURATED FROM THE BUSINESS
CUSTOMER SERVICES IN HOUSING
AGENCY AND IN COORDINATION WITH
LEGISLATIVE POLITICS STOCK. THE
BOARD BEGAN STANDING UP AGENCIES
INCLUDING SETTING UP.
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNCTIONS SUCH AS
DISCOUNTS THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE HIRING CONTRACTING
PURCHASE ABILITY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
AND I. T. SUPPORT PROVIDED BY
THE DUTCH DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. THE BOARD ALSO
ESTABLISHED ARCHITECTURAL
EVOLVING FUNDING HAVE
DESCRIPTIONS SETTING UP PHYSICAL
OFFICES AND NOT INTO CONCLUSION
OF THE PANDEMIC. IN ADDITION TO
ESTABLISH AN AGENCY REPORT ALSO
MARK AGENCY SUBSTANTIVE WORK IN
PREPARATION FOR FORMAL WILL MAKE
. THE AGENCY COMMENCED CRIMINAL
ACTIVITIES INCLUDING A DETAILED
FOR THE MODERATE INVITATIONAL
COMMENTS AND BEGAN WORKING ON
SPECIFIC TOPICS. THE BOARD THEN
APPOINTED ME AS THE DIRECTOR
DIRECTOR IN OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SOME FIVE MONTHS AGO
SEVEN CENTS WORKING ACTIVELY ON
OFFENSE TO BUILD ON THE WORK
ORDER BOARD ESTABLISHED AGENCY
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY. DRIVING
SIGNAL TRUBISKY FUNCTION.
RULEMAKING AND PROMOTING PUBLIC
AWARENESS. BUT FIRST MISTER
PRIORITY WAS TO STREAMLINE A
PROCESS WITH WITH CARTER CONTROL
AGENCIES IN ORDER TO MORE
QUICKLY- AND READILY HIGHER
INPUT HERE AS OUR AGENCY DOES
NOT HAVE DIRECT AUTHORITY FOR
YOU KNOW FUNCTION. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WE WITH THE HELP OF. OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL SERVICES
THANK. FINANCE EXISTENCE AND-
THIS YEAR WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO.
MISTER ESTABLISH KEY POSITIONS
INCLUDING AHEAD OF MINISTRATION
HR LEGAL. PARTH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
AND- THE LATTER OF WHOM YOU.
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING ONE
OF THE KEEPERS OF OUR MISSION
PUBLIC AWARENESS AND EDUCATION.
TO BEGIN RULEMAKING WE ALSO
NOTIFIED THE AGING NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT AGENCIES
PREPARE TO BEGIN RULE MAKING.
AUTHORITY FOR WHICH TRACKS
RESTORE AGENCY SIX MONTHS LATER
IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE BOARD AND I ALSO PUT YOUR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE ASSISTANCE
WITH THE AMERICAN. AS
CONTEMPLATED BY STATUTE THIS
INCLUDES BOTH LEGAL SERVICES.
AND TARGETED MR SERVICES SUCH AS
CONFERENCE SUPPORT. WORKING FOR
THE NINE HUNDRED PLUS PAGES OF
COMMENTS RECEIVED. AN ADDITIONAL
R. FOR MAKING WORK. THE PROPOSAL
READY TODAY REQUEST THIRTY FOUR
POSITIONS IN 222-022-2020 THREE
I'M GOING. TO ENABLE US TO
SATISFY INITIAL STATUTORY
OBLIGATIONS WITH A FOCUS ON WILL
MAKING AND PUBLIC AWARENESS.
THIS INITIAL STOCKTON WAS BASED
ON CAREFUL EXAMINATION
CONSULTATION WITH OTHER CATHOLIC
STUDENTS WITH SIMILAR MISSION.
NOTICE REQUEST DOES NOT RESPECT
THE FULL COMPLEMENT OF OUR STAFF
EQUIPMENT DOES NOT INCLUDE
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION AS I'VE
UNCTION ONLY BEGINS IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. NOR IS IT A
FOR ROCK ROSTERED MINISTERS OF
STAFF WAS WORTH CURRENTLY
RELYING ON OUTSIDE STAFF I'M
SORRY SERVICES. FOR HIRING
CONTRACTING. PURCHASING I. TS I
DESCRIBED ABOUT. HOUSE AGENCY
GROWS. WE REQUIRED WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON
OUR STOCKTON AND RECEIVE
APPROVAL BEFORE WE BRING IN KEY
FUNCTIONS IN HOUSE. LATER STILL
BE UTILIZING EXISTING GENERAL
FUND APPROPRIATION. FROM PROP
TWENTY FOUR- OF RBC PHILOSOPHER
NEARLY HIGHER TO KEEP FUNDS. OUR
AGENCY DESPERATELY NEEDS.
WITHOUT EVER FOR DANCING
QUESTIONS. OKAY FINANCIALLY. ANY
COMMENTS YES ENTER HOW
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME BUT WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THE
DALLAS. ARE YOU MISTER L. A. O.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL. AND. THIS IS A IT
APPEARS THAT YOU HAVE SAID NINE
HUNDRED COMMENT PAGES. FOR THIS
IS A MATTER OF NINE HUNDRED
PAGES OF COMMENTS BACK 2% TO
YOUR REGULATIONS THAT YOU'RE
BEING FOR THE PVA PROPOSING.
THIS IS IN RESPONSE OUR
PRELIMINARY COM COMMENTS. BEFORE
WE BEGIN FORMAL MAKE SO YOU HAVE
NOT EMBARKED ON RULE MAKING AT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY. LET ME
JUST ASK A QUESTION I DO OFTEN.
POST BECAUSE I WAS KIND OF THE
AUTHOR OF THIS IDEA MANY MANY
YEARS AGO WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
PASSED. ALLOWING THAT THERE
WOULD BE SOME SEMBLANCE IN ORDER
AND OF OPPORTUNITY HALF WERE.
PUBLIC INPUT PUBLIC SCRUTINY
LEGISLATIVE SCRUTINY. ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THAT ACT WAS THAT
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED. IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S ON YOUR MIND AS WE
PROCEED. INDEED REPLYING TO
THROUGH BOTH PROFESSIONAL
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE WHETHER WE
NEED TO EMBARK ON A US
REINSTATEMENT OF THE TROPICAL
KNOSSOS THAT IS UNDER WAY BUT I
PROCESS THE PROCESS FOR-
PERFORMING AT WORK IS UNDER WAY
AND WE INTEND TO AS PART OF.
ENSURE THAT WILL BE REPORTED IN
THE RULEMAKING PROCESS FOR THE
PUBLIC REVIEW IT CENTER. BUT
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU. THE
FEDERAL. NO QUESTION CENTER
pWILL MOVE. ONE TO THIRTY NINE.
THAT ON THE TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR AARON MEMBERS. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SONNY A
POLITY AND I'M THE ASSISTANT
COMMISSIONER LEGISLATION AND
REGULATIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
REAL ESTATE WE ARE PLEASED TO
PRESENT THREE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS TODAY IN OUR FIRST
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT REAL
ESTATE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS
FROM THE REAL ESTATE FUND THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY THOUSAND FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND IS CLEARED
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR I'M
GOING TO I. T. SPECIALIST USED
TO WORK ON INFORMATION SECURITY
ISSUE. CURRENTLY THERE IS ONLY
ONE POSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT
WHICH IS DEDICATED INFORMATION
SECURITY. THESE ADDITIONAL
PROPOSED POSITIONS WILL HELP THE
DEPARTMENT IMPLEMENT AUDIT
FINDINGS FROM THE BIENNIAL
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
SECURITY AUDIT. THE LAST AUDIT
IDENTIFIED SECURITY DEFICIENCIES
WHICH APARTMENT HAS BEEN WORKING
TO ADDRESS. WE'RE CURRENTLY
LACKS SUFFICIENT EXISTING
RESOURCES FULLY ADDRESSED IN A
TIMELY MANNER. THESE POSITIONS
WILL HELP PROTECT THE DEPARTMENT
AND ITS TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS FROM
CYBER CRIMINALS AND RANSOMWARE
ATTACKS. IN OUR SECOND. THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST A HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX THOUSAND IN TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE. AND A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR ON
GOING FOR ONE SENIOR MANAGEMENT
AUDITOR. THIS WILL ESTABLISH A
PERMANENT INTERNAL AUDIT
FUNCTION OF THE DEPARTMENT. THIS
POSITION WILL HELP THE
DEPARTMENT MEET STATUTORY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS.
REGARDING INTERNAL AUDIT
FUNCTIONS FOR STATE AGENCIES
WHICH SPEND MORE THAN FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. THE DEPARTMENT
CURLY HAVE STAFF ON LOAN FROM
OTHER PROGRAM AREAS TO COMPLETE
THIS FUNCTION AND NEWLY CREATED
INTERNAL AUDIT UNITS. THE
PURPOSE OF THE NEW UNIT WAS TO
PROVIDE INDEPENDENT AND
OBJECTIVE GUIDANCE TO MITIGATE
RISKS AND IMPROVE THE OPERATIONS
. IS RESPONSIBLE PERFORMING
INTERNAL AUDITS SPECIAL
MANAGEMENT REVIEWS AND FULLY
INVESTIGATIONS AND OTHER SPECIAL
REQUESTS FOR EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT. THIS BUDGET REQUEST
WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADEQUATELY STAFF A PERMANENT
INTERNAL AUDIT UNITS. AND LASTLY
THE DEPARTMENT REQUEST RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT LEGISLATION PASSED
INTO LAW LAST YEAR. THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SENATE BILL
TWO SIX THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO
WHICH CALL FOR IMPLICIT BIAS AND
FAIR HOUSING INCORPORATED INTO
THE COURSES REQUIRED FOR BOTH
INITIAL LICENSURE AS WELL AS
CONTINUING EDUCATION. REAL
ESTATE SALESPERSONS AND REAL
ESTATE BROKERS. THE DEPARTMENT
ACROSS TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN
THOUSAND AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
ONGOING. FOR TWO POSITIONS TO
IMPLEMENT THOSE CHANGES. PROGRAM
WOULD INCLUDE PROVIDING COURSE
GUIDELINES FOR PRE LICENSURE IN
CONTINUING EDUCATION COURSES.
REVIEWING AND APPROVING NEW AND
MODIFIED INITIAL LICENSURE
COURSES REVIEWING AND APPROVING
NEW AND MODIFIED CONTINUING
EDUCATION COURSES. I THINK THE
COURT I DIDN'T COURSE MATERIALS
AS WELL AS COMMUNICATING WITH
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE
FINANCE ANY OBSERVATIONS. AND
YOUR WHOLE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THE PROPOSALS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ADDRESS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SECURITY RISK
MITIGATE INTERNAL REYES IMPROVE
DEPARTMENTAL OPERATIONS CAN MEET
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED WORKLOAD
THE L. A. L. HAS YOUR CONCERNS
WITH THE FUND CONDITION OF THE
REAL ESTATE FUND PROJECTED TO BE
INSOLVENT IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE. THE DEPARTMENT
REAL ESTATE IS IN THE PROCESS OF
CONTRACTING OUT HE STUDIED TO
ASSESS WHETHER THE CHANGES ARE
NECESSARY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS IN SUPPORT OF THESE PROPOSALS
AS PROACTIVE ACTIONS ARE IN
PLACE HE'S A STAND UP
DEPARTMENTS FIND. WE ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS. THE
YOU. THE JOURNALIST. AS CHAIR
JUST COMPUTERS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
WAS ALLUDED TO- WE'VE NOTED TO
STAFF THAT ADDS THAT FIND THAT
SUPPORT STEER YOU JUST HAVE SOME
INSOLVENCY ISSUES THAT AS A
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE AND HOWEVER
HE MINISTRATION IS NOT PROPOSED
SEEN ON ANY FEE RELATED CHANGES
AT THIS TIME AND SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO MY
CONDITION OR HEALTH OF THE FIND
ON AND WE DON'T HAVE. ANY
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL'S. I
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
. I AM NONE OKAY. RIGHT THAT
GOING TO BE AN OPEN I YET AND WE
WILL GO TO NUMBER FORTY THAT
THE- TECHNICAL ASIAN SERVICES
STATEWIDE CENTRALIZED SERVICE
GENERAL FUND REQUEST. I'M FORTY.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MILES FRIEND ADAM THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- ADMINISTRATION AND
CHIEF ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY- WITH ME IS REST
NICHOLS ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY- WE HAVE TO PROPOSALS
IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY. THERE ARE
PRETTY CLOSELY RELATED THE FIRST
ONE. WOOD AB IS A FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
REQUEST FORTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT WOULD BE A
CONVERSION OF EXISTING-
TECHNOLOGY SERVICE SERVICES
REVOLVING FUND OF THORNY FROM
THAT FROM OUR COST RECOVERY FUND
YES OR AT TO THE GENERAL FUND-
WHICH WOULD. PAY FOR ALLOW US TO
SHIFT THE FUNDING FROM COST
RECOVERY TO GENERAL FUND FOR
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS THE OTHER THREE
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT MAKE UP
THE FORTY FOUR MILLION I WOULD
BE A GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
FOR- A STATEWIDE REPORTING
CONSULTING CONTRACT DOLLARS THAT
WE ARE HERE TO FOR. SOARED
WITHIN. YES OUR AFTER A FORTY-
AS I SAY THIS YEAH WOULD ALLOW
US TO BASICALLY TAKE SOME TWO
HUNDRED FIVE POSITIONS ABOUT A
FIFTH OF HIS OVERALL POSITIONS
MOVING FROM COST RECOVERY TO THE
GENERAL FUND SO WE'RE NO LONGER
COST RECOVER FROM THEM THAT
WOULD INCLUDE ALL OF THE
EXISTING OVERHEAD POSITIONS THAT
ARE STE IN T. S. R. F. AS WELL
AS SOME OF THE INDIRECT
POSITIONS AS WELL- CDT LOOKS AT
THREE COST KIND OF PLACES WHERE
DIRECT INDIRECT AND IN OVERHEAD
SO THIS WOULD AFFECT TWO OF
THOSE THREE- IT WOULD ALLOW ZTE
TO REDUCE ITS RATES BY
APPROXIMATELY 10% AND I WOULD
KNOW. THAT DAT UM C. D. IF THESE
WERE TO PASS WOULD STILL BE A
PREDOMINANTLY COST RECOVERY
ORGANIZATION THIS WOULD MOVE US
FROM ABOUT RIGHT NOW CURRENTLY-
CD T. COST RECOVERS ABOUT 86% OF
ITS COST WITH THE WITH THE
REMAINDER BEING. BY LARGE
GENERAL FUND AT THE REMAINING
40% THIS WOULD MOVE US. FROM
THAT 86% ABOUT 77% SO WE WOULD
HAVE ABOUT 23% GENERAL FUND- THE
OTHER PROPOSAL. IS A BY THE WAY
THAT IS A THREE YEAR ASK- TENDED
TO COVER TO COVER THAT SHIFT
THAT CONVERSION THREE YEARS FOR
THE NEXT ONE IS ALSO A THREE
YEAR ASKING IT IS. A TEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR. GENERAL
FUND ASK- YOUR COVER A REVENUE
HOLD IT IS GOING TO BE CREATED-
BY TWO OF OUR LARGER CUSTOMERS-
MOVING OUT OF THE DATA CENTER
LEAST SOME OF THEIR OPERATIONS
AND APPLICATIONS OUT OF THE DATA
CENTER. LIKE A LOT OF B. BECAUSE
IT IS A DATA CENTER IN IT HAS A
FAIRLY HIGH FIXED COST
STRUCTURE- BETWEEN- PERSONAL
SERVICES- AND THE HARDWARE AND-
PERCH. WE MAKE TO MAINTAIN THAT
CENTER- IN WE LOSE. CUSTOMERS
WHAT WHEN CUSTOMERS MIGRATE OFF
FROM- AND GO TO THE CLOUD OR OR
OR WHEREVER THEY'RE GOING IN
THIS CASE- HE- WE CAN DECREASE
OUR COST STRUCTURE IS QUICKLY AS
AS WE FEEL THE REVENUE HERE SO
THIS TEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHAT. WOULD COVER THAT
HOLDS THAT THE REQUEST IS FOR
THREE YEARS ON BOTH CASES YOU
HELP TO GIVE CDT- THE RUNWAY
THAT IT NEEDS TO REALLY
REEVALUATE ITS ITS COST RECOVERY
MODEL- IN ITS SERVICE DELIVERY
AND DO BRING. IT'S COSTS IN LINE
WITH ITS READINESS AND WITH THAT
I AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS EARLY THANK YOU
FINANCE. HELLO RYAN ONE OF THE
FINANCE WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON
DISPOSAL I GET. VERY LITTLE
JOURNALIST. BRIAN METZGER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED ONLY BUDGET YOUR
FUNDING FOR BOTH PROPOSALS. AND
TO REJECT REQUESTED OUT OF YOUR
FUNDING TO ENSURE THAT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT CONTINUES
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS. OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS RAISE QUESTIONS
ABOUT CTA'S BUSINESS MODEL FOR
PROVIDING IT SERVICES. THESE
PROPOSALS NOT ONLY SEEK TO
ADDRESS REVENUE LOSSES BUT
DECLINING CUSTOMER BASE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT STATE DATA CENTER.
ONE REASON APPEARS TO BE SOME
STATE DATA CENTER RATES ARE NOT
COMPETITIVELY PRICED AS SHOWN IN
THE AGENDA. ANOTHER REASON IS
DIRECT RATE COMPARISON BETWEEN
PRIVATE VENDORS IN THE STATE
DATA CENTER INCLUDING BENEFITS
SPECIFIC TO STATE SERVICES IS
DIFFICULT FOR STATE ENTITIES TO
UNDERTAKE. THE PROPOSALS AS
CURRENTLY PRESENTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO ARE MISSING KEY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
ANTICIPATED RATE REEVALUATION
PROCESS THAT IS EXPECTED TO
LIMIT ADDITIONAL REVENUE LOSSES.
AND MAKE STATE DATA DATA CENTER
REITS MORE COMPETITIVE. BASED ON
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE IMPACTS OF
THIS PROCESS ON CORE SERVICES
PROVIDED TO STATE ENTITIES AND
THE ANTICIPATED SHIFT THE
FUNDING FOR SOME I. T. SERVICES.
TO THE GENERAL FUND IN THE
FUTURE SUGGEST A MORE ACTIVE
ROLE FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN ITS
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROCESS.
THEREFORE WE ALSO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTION PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
DIRECTS DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
DEFINE THE RATE REEVALUATION
PROCESS OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS AND PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
INCLUDING THE THREE COMPONENTS
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE AGENDA.
IN THE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. I HAVE JUMP ON THE
POINT IF I MAY THE- PRINT
CONTROL LANGUAGE TO SUGGEST THEY
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
REALLY MEANS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
THERE HAS TO BE MORE OF AN
ENFORCEMENT. ABILITY I THANK.
AND TO ME THIS IS ONE OF THE
MORE TROUBLED AGENCIES IN STATE
GOVERNMENT FOR DECADES OUR- TECH
PROJECTS HAVE GONE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. OVER BUDGET. FEW IF ANY
OF COMING IN ON TIME. AND I
CERTAINLY CONCUR WITH THE
ANALYST ABOUT NO THREE YEAR
FUNDING- IT JUST SEEMS THAT THIS
THIS AGENCY PARTICULARLY WOULD
REQUIRE A LOT MORE. SCRUTINY AND
OVERSIGHT BECAUSE OF ITS
INHERENT PROBLEMS. AND BECAUSE
OF THE TREMENDOUS COST. LOOKING
AT THE FOR YOUR ANALYSTS- LITTLE
CHART HERE ON PAGE FIFTY SIX.
COMPARING CD KEY AND MAJOR OTHER
CORPORATIONS AMAZON MICROSOFT
GOOGLE IBM. CAN SOMEONE IN THE
AGENCY TELL ME WHY SEARCHES
INCREDIBLE DISCREPANCY IN THOSE
COSTS. THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
THIS IS ROSS NICHOLS IN THE
ACTING DIRECTOR OF PARKING
TECHNOLOGY THIS PROPOSAL TO HAVE
IN FRONT OF YOU IS ACTUALLY
FULLY INTENDED TO ADDRESS THAT
DISCREPANCY SO THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDES MANY
SERVICES- YOU MENTIONED ARE YOU
ALLUDED TO OVERSIGHT SERVICES.
RUNS A PROJECT WE PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT- AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
SERVICES TO THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
IN OUR RATE STRUCTURE RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE'RE COST RECOVERY WHAT
HAPPENS IS AS WE BUILD THOSE
RATES FOR STORAGE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE LINE ITEMS THAT YOU SEE
IN THAT TABLE. THAT LINE ITEM
INCLUDES NOT ONLY THE DIRECT
COST OF THE STAFFING AND THE
EQUIPMENT AND SOFTWARE NECESSARY
TO PROVIDE STORAGE BUT IT ALSO
INCLUDES THE STAFF IN OUR LEGAL
OPTIONS IN OUR HR ALL. OLLIE THE
OTHER ANCILLARY OPERATIONS OF
CBP CONTRACTS ABOVE AND BEYOND
THE DIRECT SERVICES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO OUR CUSTOMERS AND
BECAUSE OF THAT IT DOES
ARTIFICIALLY INFLATE. THE RATES
THAT WE HAVE TO CHARGE BOTH
STATE ENTITIES AND TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT THAT'S STRIVE
TO OUR SERVICES WE HAVE QUITE A
NUMBER. OF CONSUMERS THAT ARE
NOT STATE AGENCIES ORGANIZATIONS
AND SO OUR INTENT IS TO
RESTRUCTURE. OUR- OUR BILLING
MECHANISM ARE RATE SETTING
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE NOT ONLY
THAT OUR RATES ARE COMPETITIVE
BUT THE TRANSPARENT SO THAT
ORGANIZATIONS KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING. FOR WHEN THEY
SUBSCRIBE TO OUR SERVICE. LET ME
THAT INQUIRED OF JAN WAS JUST
THIS MAKE SURE. TO YOU AND- IT
IS A WAY TO AND THIS WE JUST
SHE- COSTS AROUND AND NOT REALLY
MAKING A SUBSTANTIVE DOES
SOMETHING DIFFERENT DIFFERENCE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN I
THINK THE QUESTION WE EVER REYES
BY INCLUDING THIS SHARK IS
WHETHER OR NOT THE PROPOSED
SHIFT OF THESE INTERNAL
ADMINISTRATIVE RESOURCES FROM
COST RECOVERY TO THE GENERAL
FUND WHICH IS ANTICIPATED TO
BRING RATES DOWN BY ABOUT TEN
PERCENT. ACROSS THE BOARD OR ON
AVERAGE I SHOULD SAY- WHAT'S
FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESSED THE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN WHAT CDC IS
CHARGING FOR SOME SERVICES AND
WHAT THE PRIVATE SECTOR CAN
OFFER- WE ALSO WOULD NOTE THAT
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION THEY ALSO
NOTED THAT SOME OF THEIR
SERVICES EVEN IF THEY WERE
REDUCED TO DIRECT COSTS ONLY.
WOULD STILL NOT BE COMPETITIVE
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR SO
ABSENT YOU KNOW IN DIRECTOR
OVERHEAD COSTS THERE ARE SOME
SERVICES THAT ARE SIMPLY NOT AS
COMPETITIVE- AND SO WE THINK
THAT THIS SUGGEST AGAIN BUT THE
NEED FOR RE RE EVALUATION
PROCESS AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
THAT WILL BE TAKING PLACE OVER
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. BUT WE
THINK THE LEGISLATURE AN
INTEREST- IN CONTINUING TO
OVERSEE THAT PROCESS AND MAKE
SURE THAT SOME OF THE OBJECTIVES
ABOUT PROCESSOR MADE CLEAR FOR
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. I WOULD
HAVE. IT IF YOU WOULD COME
FORWARD TO US FROM FROM
SUGGESTIONS OF HOW THE
LEGISLATURE COULD EXERT MORE
FORMAL AND REGULAR AND IN DEPTH.
OVERSIGHT OF THESE TECHNOLOGICAL
OF ACQUISITIONS. IT JUST TO ME
VERY VERY OPPRESSIVE OUT OF
CONTROL AND NON FUNCTIONAL
ALMOST ALL OF OUR MAJOR HI TECH
UPGRADES AND SOME TWENTY YEARS
IN MY EXPERIENCE OF THE FAILURES
ARE CREDIBLY CAUSTIC. OF SENATE
CABALLERO. WHAT I WANT TO AGREE
WITH THEM WAIT WHAT'S JUST BEEN
SAID I GUESS WHAT I AM WHEN I
READ THIS EARLIER MY CONCERN WAS
IT JUST SEEMED LIKE WE WERE
SHIFTING THE COST FROM ONE IT'S
A LITTLE BIT LIKE A SHELL GAME
AND- AND PART OF THE CONCERN I
HAVE IS THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO KNOW WHAT IT COSTS FOR US
TO RUN A DEPARTMENT TO DO
SOMETHING. RATHER THAN THAN-
CONTRACT FOR IT AND I'M NOT FOR
CONTRACTING OUT BUT- BUT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE SOME OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS THAT DO SERVICE FOR
OTHERS- A LITTLE BIT- LEANER AND
MEANER AND WE JUST GOT TO FIGURE
OUT IF THAT IF THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IN THIS PARTICULAR
INSTANCE- SO AYE I SUPPORT THE
ONE YEAR AND THEN I THINK WE
HAVE TO BE INVOLVED IN THE- IN
THE ANALYSIS OF COST RECOVERY.
AND HOW WE DO THAT IS GOING TO
BE VERY VERY DIFFICULT- I'D BE
MANY TO SPECIAL COMMITTEE JUST
TO LOOK AT THAT. I'M MORE MOST
OF A MIND TO SENATOR THAT WE DO
CREATE A LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE. CENTER OFF YOUR
THOUGHT. FAMOUS VENTURE WHY I
JUST WANT TO SAY. THAT I'VE SEEN
A GREAT DEAL OF IMPROVEMENT IN
CDC'S PERFORMANCE. AND I. T.
PROJECT- DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITY SINCE I LANDED IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE. OBVIOUSLY THE LARGE
PROJECTS THAT WERE. INITIATED
DECADES AGO LITERALLY. AND THAT
UNFORTUNATELY ARE STILL ONGOING-
SEEM OBVIOUSLY TO BE AN
EXCEPTION BUT- AGAIN. THOSE SEEM
TO BE AN EXCEPTION I JUST WANNA.
SAY THAT ABOUT CDC AND HER
PERSONALITY SEE AN- APPRECIATIVE
I AM OF WHAT YOU TRY TO DO. FOR
ALL THE REST OF US MY QUESTION
HOWEVER AND I LOOKED WHEN I
LOOKED AT THIS I WANT TO READ
THIS. PORTION OF THE ANALYSIS
SO. I GUESS MY QUESTION IS WHY
WHY DO WE HAVE A STATE. THE DATA
CENTER- IF IN FACT. ENTITIES ARE
MIGRATING. TO THE CLOUD. AND
OTHER PER. FOR A DATA STORAGE
AND THE LIKE. STE THANK YOU ARE
THE SENATE ROTH FOR THE QUESTION
AGAIN REST NICHOLS THE DIRECTOR
OF C. T. R. OUR STATE DATA
CENTER HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME WE HAVE A LARGE
MAINFRAME SYSTEM RUNS THERE IN
ADDITION TO A NUMBER OF OTHER
SERVICES A BULK OF STATE
ORGANIZATIONS DO HAVE THEIR
SYSTEMS ON SITE WITH WITH THEIR
CONFIDENTIAL INSTANT. AND
IMPORTANT DATA STATE SAYING AT
OUR SITE IT DOESN'T PROVIDE
ECONOMIES OF SCALE BUT IT IS NOT
THE PERFECT SOLUTION FOR EVERY
SYSTEMS OUT THERE AS SOME OF THE
NEWER SYSTEMS COME UP IN THEIR
CAPABILITIES HIM PRIVATE SECTOR
WE'RE ACTUALLY TO SORTING
PROCESS TO ALLOW OUR OUR STATE
ORGANIZATIONS TO CONSUME
APPROPRIATE- SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE PRIVATE MARKET.
AND IN SO THAT A SPECIFICALLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH A COUPLE
OF OUR LARGE TENANTS IN THE
DATACENTER MOVING OFF OF THE
MAINFRAME AND IN THE CLOUD BASED
SOLUTIONS WHICH GENERALLY ARE
CAN BE A GOOD THING FOR THE
STATE BECAUSE IT DOESN'T REDUCE
THE COST OF OPERATIONS. IN THE
MEANTIME THOUGH WE STILL HAVE. A
LARGE NUMBER I SPOKE WITH IN THE
STATE AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT USE OF SERVICE SO. IT'S NOT
AS SIMPLE AS AS A QUICK
MIGRATION AND RANKLY OF
SERVICES ARE NOT ALWAYS THE BEST
ANSWERS ARE NOT ALWAYS SOLUTIONS
OUT THERE THAT ARE EASILY USED
AS A SUBSCRIPTION WILL BE OUR
BUSINESS OUT THERE AND WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE DATA THAT'S
INVOLVED IN THOSE SYSTEMS TO SEE
IF WE- WANT TO TAKE THE RISK OF
HAVING THAT. MAINTAIN FIVE
SEPARATE ENTITY BUT TO YOUR
POINT WE DO NEED TO REEVALUATE
THAT BUSINESS MODEL THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT TO DO
RATHER THAN JUST CONTINUING THE
PRACTICE THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE
LITERALLY FOR DECADES. OUR WHOLE
INTENT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE LOOKING AT EACH AND EVERY
SERVICE OPERATED MUCH MORE LIKE
A PRIVATE BUSINESS THAT WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IT COSTS TO PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE WERE MEASURING
EFFECTIVENESS NOBODY CREATED BY
THAT SERVICE. FRANKLY IF IT IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE WE NEED TO SAY
THAT OUT. LOUD IN EITHER THE
COMMISSION THAT SERVICE S. OR
FOR WAYS TO ITS THAT IT IS MUCH
MORE. FIVE THAT IS AREN'T WITH
THIS. PROM WELL THAT'S WHAT I
MEAN I WAS. TO FIND A IF THERE
WERE. DATUS A- ISSUE TO ON THE
NAY OF THE AGENCY. LAW
ENFORCEMENT PUBLIC SAFETY OTHER
TYPES OF- OF DATA SYSTEMS THAT
YOU UNDER LEE MAINTAIN WHERE.
TRANSFERRED TO THE CLOUD OR SOME
OTHER- EXTERNAL- STORAGE OF FOR
WANT OF A BETTER WORD STORAGE
PLACE STORAGE FACILITY. WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE OR RISKY I
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT I I'M
ALSO NOT. UNMINDFUL OF THE FACT
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH PEOPLE'S
JOBS. AND THAT'S ALWAYS A
CONCERN TO US IN TERMS OF MAKING
SURE WE HAVE A PERSONAL PLAN. IF
IN FACT WE HAVE JOBS ON THE
LINE. OF DEPENDING ON WHAT YOUR
YOUR YOUR OF BUSINESS PLAN
REEVALUATION LOOKS LIKE AND WHAT
THE- ULTIMATE OUTCOME TURNS OUT
TO BE. MAYBE YOU MENTIONED IT
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE FOR THIS
BUSINESS PLAN REEVALUATION THE-
THE REVIEW IN THE EVALUATION OF
THE CONTINUED VIABILITY OF THE
STATE DATA CENTER. THAT'S WHAT
WE ARE PLANNING IN THAT THREE
YEAR CYCLE SO IN THAT THREE YEAR
CYCLE AND WE ABSOLUTELY INTEND
TO BE VERY TRANSPARENT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH L. A. L.
ORDER MEMBERS. TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION-
BACKBOARD JUST LIKE TRACTOR
STAKEHOLDERS- BUT IN THAT THREE
YEAR PERIOD WE WANT TO AND-
REALLY INVESTIGATE EACH OF THOSE
SERVICES. AND DETERMINED NOT
ONLY IF THE SERVICE IS VIABLE
WHAT IS THE BEST MECHANISM TO
OPERATE THAT SERVICE. ARE WE DO
WANT TO DECOUPLE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY THE DATA CENTER AND
IN OUR TECHNOLOGY ORGANIZATION
FROM SOME OF THE SERVICES WE
PROVIDE AS AN OVERSIGHT%
ORGANIZATION FOR SECURITY
ORGANIZATION. IN PAST BUDGET
ACTIONS WE'VE ALREADY FUNDED
STATE SECURITY OPERATIONS
INDEPENDENTLY BECAUSE THAT IS
SUCH A SIGNIFICANT FOCUS IN OUR
CYBER SECURITY PROGRAM. ARE WE
WANT TO DO THE SAME THING REALLY
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE SERVICES
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
OPERATING BOTH AT THE PEAK OF
AFFECTING US. IN FINANCIAL
STABILITY. WELL I'M CERTAINLY IN
FAVOR OF MAKING SURE THAT THE-
THE I. T. A DEVELOPMENT AND
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION THAT YOU OR
SOMEONE YOU WERE- OPERATION
PERFORM- REMAINS OF NOT ONLY
VIABLE BUT ROBUST BECAUSE I
THINK THAT'S IN PART THE
SOLUTION. TO THE SITUATION THAT
MY COLLEAGUE- THE CENTERS TO MY
LEFT WAS THE VICE CHAIR WAS
SPEAKING ABOUT EARLIER THANK YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DO THANK YOU A.
MISSED BY FEAR THANK YOU. WILL I
THINK WE WANT. KEEP A CLOSE EYE
ON THIS ONE AND IT'S- I THINK
WE'VE GOT TO BE SOME MORE BILL
TO IT WE CAN'T GIVEN TOO MUCH
LET OF TO BE TO- SCOTT EARNED
THE- AND THAT- THAT PLAN. I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT THE VERY VERY
SPUR. AND PRISON ON A TIME NOT
LOOSE WHEN WE WOULD GET AROUND
TO IT BUT DISTRIBUTION TIME
CERTAIN OF THE PROFFERING OF
THIS THIS PLANT. CAN YOU DO THAT
. YES SIR IN FACT WE WOULD
WELCOME DOING THAT EVEN OUTSIDE
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS NOT
NECESSARILY WAITING UNTIL NEXT
YEAR AT THIS TIME WHILE WORKING
WITH OUR AWAY- TO FIGURE OUT AN
APPROPRIATE MECHANISM OF THAT'S
REPORTING THROUGH JAIL BC OR
SOME OF THE- THANK YOU. AND I
WITH MY PART REQUESTED LAST TO
WORK WITH YOU TO ENSURE THAT
DOES HAPPEN WE DON'T JUST FORGET
ABOUT IT. ISSUE FORTY ONE
FACILITIES MANAGEMENT DIVISION
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JACQUELINE CAMPION I AM THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WITH ME AS JAMAL ON IN JEOPARDY
DIRECTOR FOR THE FACILITIES
MANAGEMENT DIVISION OUR PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU TODAY REQUEST ONE
HUNDRED POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME COSTS FORTY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
REPAIR AND MODERNIZE ELEVATOR
SYSTEMS AND THREE STATE
BUILDINGS. AND DIRECT DIGITAL
CONTROL SYSTEMS IN EIGHT EIGHT
BUILDINGS FOR THE ELEVATOR
PROJECT INDUSTRY STANDARDS
PROVIDE THAT ELEVATOR EQUIPMENT
SHOULD BE MODERNIZED EVERY
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS
DEPENDING ON THE TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT AND HOW HEAVILY ITS
USE AND ALL THREE OF THESE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE PROPOSED FOR
MODERNIZATION ARE AT OR PAST
THEIR USEFUL LIFE AND NEED TO BE
MODERNIZED TO IMPROVE SYSTEM
EFFECTIVENESS ENSURE SAFETY. AND
PREVENT POTENTIAL INJURY OR
ENTRAPMENT. ADDITIONALLY FOR THE
DIRECT DIGITAL CONTROL PROJECT
THESE ARE SYSTEMS THAT CONSIST
OF SMART EQUIPMENT THAT CAN
COMMUNICATE DIGITALLY WITH
OPERATORS EACH OTHER. HVAC
CONTROLS LIGHTING FIRE ALARM AND
SUPPRESSION SYSTEMS AND IN SOME
CASES LOCAL UTILITIES. THESE
SYSTEMS PERFORM DIAGNOSTICS
DETECT FAULTS AND HELP REDUCE
DOWNTIME AND MAINTENANCE COSTS
IT CAN ALSO INCREASE ENERGY
SAVINGS ANYWHERE FROM 13266% BY
OPTIMIZING EQUIPMENT SETTINGS
AND TIMERS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND AGAIN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR- AND MYSELF WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE- THANK YOU. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON NUMBER IS ILLICITLY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE HAVE
NOTHING TO ADD BETTER HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. ANALYST.
THANK YOU REYES CHURCH OF
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY CONCERNS WITH THESE DETAILS
PROPOSALS. I'M JUST KIND OF THE
- BEING TRIED HERE BUT TO. AS
WE'VE MOVED INTO THE NEW SWING
SPACE- EXPERIENCING SOME OF THE
DIFFICULTIES OF THE ELEVATORS I
HAVE FOUND MYSELF PINING FOR THE
GOOD OLD DAYS WHEN WE ACTUALLY
HAD ELEVATOR OPERATORS. AND THE
OLD SYSTEM IF YOU WILL- AGAIN
BEING SOMEWHAT FACETIOUS ABOUT
IT VICTOR. MODERNIZATION
SOMETIMES HAS ITS DEFICIENCIES
WE'RE GOING THROUGH SOME GROWING
PAINS RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU THEN
I THINK WE HAVE THE NEXT ONE
WOULD BE THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL. THE AND WITH. FORTY
TWO. I DON'T FORTY TWO MEDICARE. TELL WE'RE READY FOR YOU ALL-
HELLO ARE. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AYE MAN DOWN
CRAWFORD EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE ARTS COUNCIL WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED AND I FEEL
THE NEED TO DESIGNATE. OUR
CULTURAL DISTRICTS IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WITH AB ONE
EIGHTY NINE AND I'M FUNDED
MANDATE AND WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
THE GOVERNOR FOR VALUING THIS
PROGRAM TO THE EXTENT THAT HE
INCLUDED IN HIS PROPOSED BUDGET.
AND ARE EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND OUR STATE'S COHORT OF
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. WITH THE B.
C. REQUEST FOR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS TO
EXPAND THE PILOT COHORT. OF
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A BRIEF AMOUNT OF TIME
TO EXPLAIN TO YOU HOW THIS
FUNDING WILL IMPACT THE CURRENT
DISTRICTS AND THE EXPANDED
DISTRICTS. OUR COUNCIL
PROHIBITED DURING THE PANDEMIC
TO ADDRESS THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON OUR ARTS COMMUNITIES
STATEWIDE. THE EXPANSION OF
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PRIORITIZED
EQUITABLE ECONOMIC INCLUSION
FOCUSING ON COMMUNITY BUILDING
AND NOURISHING. CULTURAL
IDENTITY AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE CITY GOVERNMENT AND
BUSINESSES WHILE PREVENTING
DISPLACEMENT. THIS IS WHAT WE DO
AT THE C. A. C. WHEN THE FIRST
COOPER WAS ESTABLISHED ARTS
COUNCIL BEGAN BY CONDUCTING
ONLINE SURVEYS INTERVIEWS. AND
PUBLIC INPUT MEETINGS WERE HELD
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE PLAN TO
USE THOSE BEST PRACTICES FOR OUR
PUBLIC INPUT SESSIONS AS WELL AS
BORROWING FROM THE BEST
PRACTICES WE'VE RECENTLY YEARS.
IN DEVELOPING THE CALIFORNIA
CREATIVE CORE PROGRAM GUIDELINES
USE LOOK UTILIZING COMMUNITY
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT ANALYSTS
ANALYSTS THAT CONSISTED OF
ARTISTS CULTURE BEARERS. EIGHT
OF INDIVIDUALS ARE SAID
MINISTRATIONS IN THIS
ADMINISTRATORS IN THIS CASE IT
WOULD BE BUSINESS LEADERS AND
MUNICIPALITY LEADERS. FROM
PRIORITY POPULATIONS THAT ARE TO
BE ENGAGED. AFTER WE VISITED
INITIALLY AND EVALUATED THE
EXISTING FOURTEEN CULTURAL
DISTRICTS.WE BELIEVE THAT THE
STRUCTURE OF THEIR OUR REACH
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT IN OUR
CREATE A CORD DEVELOPMENTS IS A
VIBRANT MODEL THAT WE CAN USE
WHILE WE ROLL OUT THIS NEW
COHORT AS SOON AS THE FUNDS
BECOME AVAILABLE FOR THE
EXPANSION OF THE COVERT THE
COUNCIL PLANS TO DO SITE VISITS
AND WILL ASSESS THE HEALTH AND
NEEDS OF THE ORIGINAL FOURTEEN
DISTRICTS. WILL ALSO DO REGIONAL
LISTENING TOURS PUBLIC INPUT
MEETINGS OF REGIONAL COMMUNITY
PANELS FORMED ON ON THE MODERATE
JUST SPOKE ABOUT TO INFORM US
ABOUT THE NEEDS AND CHALLENGES
REGIONALLY THIS EVALUATION WILL
DETERMINE HOW THE CDC CAN BEST
SUPPORT THE EXISTING COHORT
INCLUDING. THE AMOUNT TO BE
DISTRIBUTED TO THE EXISTING
DISTRICTS FOR STAFFING AND
BRANDING. THESE FOURTEEN WILL
ULTIMATELY SERVE AS MENTORS TO A
NEW COHORT OF DISTRICTS AS WELL
AS TO THE PLANNING DISTRICTS.
IT'LL ASO INFORM THE
CERTIFICATION OF TEN MORE
DISTRICTS. AND WHEN I SAID
PLANNING I MEAN THAT WE WOULD
IDENTIFIES FIVE EMERGING
DISTRICTS WHERE WE CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. SO THAT THEY
COULD INCREASE THEIR CAPACITY TO
ACTUALLY BECOME APPLICANTS FOR
THE CULTURAL DISTRICT PROGRAM.
DISTRICTS SO USE THE FUNDS FOR
MARKETING SIGNAGE BANNERS
DEVELOPER BRANDS. IRWIN HAVE
CETERA IN STAFF TO COORDINATE
THE NECESSARY PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN ARTISTS CITY PARTNERS
AND BUSINESSES. THE CRITERIA
USED TO SUPPORT THE GRANTS IS
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO REPRESENT
THE TRUE COLLABORATION
PARTNERSHIPS THAT EXIST ALREADY
BETWEEN ARTISTS CITY PARTNERS
AND BUSINESS MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
RACIAL EQUITY ACCESSIBILITY AND
THAT NO CONFLICT EXISTS BETWEEN
THE BUSINESS AND THE CULTURAL
DISTRICT AND THE ARTISTS MAKING
A LIVING. AND CONTINUING TO
RESIDE IN THE AREA OF THE
DISTRICT. A PANEL OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM EXISTING
CULTURAL DISTRICTS AND
STAKEHOLDERS WILL RANK THE
APPLICANTS BASED ON THE
GUIDELINES THAT ARE DEVELOPED.
ALL THE WORK THAT WE DO AT THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IS
GROUNDED IN USING A RACIAL
EQUITY LANDS A GOOD EXAMPLE WITH
THE WORK WE DID WITH THAT. YES
THE WORK THAT WE DID WITH THE
CREATIVE CORE WE INVITED
REGIONAL REPRESENTATIVES MEMBERS
OF THE VARIOUS COMMUNITIES. WHO
WOULD PERSONALLY REPRESENT THE
COMMUNITY THEY LIVE AND WORK IN
THE NORTH OTHERWISE THEY HAVE
BOTH FEET. IN THE REGION. WHERE
THE WORK WILL BE DONE. BASED ON
THE INITIAL OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE EXISTING.
OUR CULTURAL DISTRICTS CHC OR
EXCESS WELL ASSESS THE ALLOWABLE
COSTS FOR CULTURAL DISTRICTS. ON
WHAT I HAD MENTIONED BEFORE
COSTIKYAN INCLUDES SIGNAGE
BANNERS MARKETING ARTIST
MAKERSPACE AND STAFF THAT
SUPPORT PROJECT COORDINATION
FUNDS WILL BE USED TO STRENGTHEN
RELATIONS BETWEEN BUSINESSES
CITIES AND ARTIST COMMUNITIES TO
DEVELOP PRIDE AND STEWARDSHIP
REPLACE. RAGING RETENTION OF
CULTURAL ASSETS ACTIVELY WORKING
TO MITIGATE DISPLACEMENT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE FIRST
ROUND OF FUNDING IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND DURING THAT COHORTS-
FUNDING WAS FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WHICH IS NOT GIVEN
IN RESPONSE TO A NEED AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WE WANT TO REALLY
THOROUGHLY EXAMINE WHAT THE
MEDIA IS OUT THERE IN THE FIELD.
BY CONDUCTING OUR REGION
INCORPORATING PUBLIC INPUT AS WE
DEVELOP THE GUIDELINES. I'M HERE
WITH- DEPUTY DIRECTOR. HE WORRY
THE ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE ABOUT THE GROWTH AND
EXPANSION OF THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS. AS WELL AS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
THE POETS LAUREATE PROGRAM
ALTHOUGH I SEE ON THIS ITEM
WE'RE- TALKING MAINLY ABOUT
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND FROM FINANCE. MARK
JOHNSON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NOTHING TO ADD ATTHIS TIME BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE GREAT
THANK YOU ALEJO'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST COMPUTERS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I'M IS SO AS WITH THE
NOTED- THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE EIGHTY SIGNIFICANT AND-
I'M NOT A ONE TIME FUNDING FOR
THE CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROGRAM
AND IN PARTICULAR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A ONE TIME FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. AND WHILE OF THIS
PROGRAM IS BEING DISCUSSED IN
THE CONTEXT OF CONTINUING A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT WAS APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND HAS BEEN
A LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY. ON THE
PROGRAM WAS HAS NOT BEEN FUNDED
BEFORE AND L. AS MISS BROWN
CRAWFORD INDICATED THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING TO EACH DISTRICT HAS
BEEN. SORT OF NOMINAL AMOUNT
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
INTO THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
FUNDING LEVEL IS I SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER. THAN WHAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED IN THE PAST INTO THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF
SORT OF A NEW FUNDING PROGRAM.
AND THE ORIGINAL PILOT PROGRAM
IT DID FIND AND SOME CONCERNS
WITH THAT FOURTEEN DISTRICTS
THAT WERE ESTABLISHED. I'M IN
PARTICULAR AND THAT HE
DISTRICTS- DIDN'T DIDN'T REALLY
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S RACIAL AND
ETHNIC HERITAGE AND DIVERSITY-
AS WELL AS- A LACKING OF CLEAR
GOALS AND EXPECTATIONS. I'M FOR
THE DISTRICTS AND FOR THE
PROGRAM. I'M IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS POTENTIALLY PROMISING
IT'S SEEKING TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE CONCERNS THAT WERE FOUND
IN THE- REVIEW AND EVALUATION OF
A PILOT PROGRAM- HOWEVER WE FIND
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN KEY
DETAILS OF THAT THE PROPOSAL
THAT ARE STILL LACKING. IN
PARTICULAR AND IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
FUNDS WOULD BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN
EXISTING DISTRICTS AND NEW
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. I'M AND-
SPECIFIC PARAMETERS ON THE
ALLOWABLE USE OF FRIENDS AND
SOME POTENTIAL FUND ALLOWABLE
USES THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED TODAY- BUT THERE HAS
BEEN NOTHING I'M DETAILED IN THE
PROPOSAL. I'M. ABOUT HOW THAT
WOULD BE DETERMINE ANNA MORE
COPPER LET AT THE FUNDS MIGHT BE
- WHAT CHRIST WOULDUSED TO
AWARD THE GRAN AND A- THAT GREEN
TEA. I'M WHAT OF COOL AND HOW
WOULD BE HONEST BY THE ARTS. AND
HOW THOSE MIGHT BE MEASURE. AND
ARTS COUNCIL UNIQUE HER OFFICE
THAT MORE DETAILS ON THIS. WOULD
BE AVAILABLE LATER IN THE SPRING
- WE FIND THAT WITHOUT SUCH
DETAILS IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
DETERMINE THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THE PROPOSAL WOULD MEET THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES. ON AS
WELL AS ADDRESS THE ISSUES
AROUND LACK OF DIVERSITY FOR THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROGRAM.
IBM'S THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
PROPOSED USE THAT FUNDING WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE FOR THE FACT THAT
THESE ARE ONE TIME FRIENDS
RATHER THAN ONGOING FINDS. AND
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WITHHOLD ACTION
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL UNTIL
THE ARTS COUNCIL IS ABLE TO
PROVIDE SUFFICIENT DETAILS ABOUT
HOW THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED. AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THEY YOU
I'M NOT GOING TO MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE VICE. WHAT TO THE TO
THE CHAIR IDEA. HAVE A GREAT
AFFINITY FOR THE ARTS COUNCIL IS
ONE OF MY FAVORITE. AGENCY BUT-
TO THIS VERY POINT IS I'VE
REVIEWED THESE CULTURAL
DISTRICTS. I IN I READ THE
CRITERIA PRESERVATION
DESIGNATION AFRICAN AMERICAN
BLACK NATIVE AMERICAN CHINESE
AMERICAN CULTURE DISTRICTS IN
THE NEXT COHORT. NUMBER TWO
PRIORITIES DESIGNATION OF
DESTRUCTION AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE UNDERFUNDED OR NOT
DIRECTLY FUNDED BY THE CHC. MY
INTEREST IS THE RURAL COUNTIES
MANY OF WHICH ARE MINORITY
DOMINATED. N. THIS LIST DOES NOT
SHOW VERY MUCH MONEY GOING INTO
THE RURAL COUNTIES. AND I GATHER
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS IT IS THAT CORRECT. YES
THAT IS CORRECT YEAH G.
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY IS A BIG PART
OF THIS AND I THINK IT IS
NECESSARY FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- IN AND WE CAN PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL HE M. AS- WAS MENTIONED
IN. BUT WE ALSO ARE VERY
COMMITTED TO DOING A FIELD
SCANNER THOROUGH FIELD SCANNED
INTO MY ACTUALLY LISTEN AS WE DO
THAT. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE KNOW
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THROUGH ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. YOU KNOW
WHAT IS NEEDED IN THIS PERIOD OF
TIME. WELL YOU KNOW THE ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT THE RECOVERY.
THE VILLAGE TO THE RURAL
COUNTIES SO MUCH OF OUR HISTORY
. THE CALIFORNIA IS LOCATED IN
THESE RURAL COUNTIES PHIL OF. IN
THIS EVENT IN THE- DOCUMENT WE
HAVE HERE JUST THE ANALYSIS. I
DON'T SEE ANYTHING ABOUT
GEOGRAPHIC I READ ITEMS ONE AND
TWO VERBATIM BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE
AS YOU PROCEED SOMETHING ABOUT
THE GEOGRAPHIC. DISTRIBUTIONS TO
AND YOUR CONSIDERATION OF YOUR
OF YOUR YOUR FUNDING FOR IF
YOU'RE CULTURAL DISTRICT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE COUNCIL'S PRIORITIES AND I
CAN ASSURE YOU WE WILL ADDRESS
GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY AND THAT'S AND
NOW I'M AYE I THINK YOU KNOW
THAT IF. I WEAR A RURAL ADVOCACY
HAVE QUITE A BIT YOU DO I KNOW
THAT THANK YOU. SENATOR RON
NUMBER- CABALLERO. YEAH THIS IS
A WHOLE DOOR OPEN ITEM SO I DO
WANT TO SEE A LOT MORE DETAIL I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE- THE LACK
OF GEOGRAPHICAL DIVERSITY APART
FROM THE FACT THAT- THAT D. D.
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE SITE'S.
IN REGARDS TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IS PRETTY LOPSIDED
AS WELL I LOVE THE ARTS COUNCIL
AYE AYE I THINK THAT- YOU HAVE
A- A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE
. PEOPLE IN ESPECIALLY NOW WITH
. WITH HOW ISOLATED AND-
RESTRICTED EVERYBODY'S LIFE SAID
HAVE BEEN. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET INVOLVED IN THE ARTS IS JUST
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUT- I HAVE
A NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES AND WHEN
I TOOK A LOOK AT THIS THERE WAS
NOTHING IN THIS IN THE CENTRAL
PORTION OF THE STATE AT ALL.
AND- AND MISS A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY YOU KNOW WE TEND. DO
ARTS AND MONTEREY COUNTY PEOPLE
ALWAYS GO TO THE PENINSULA BUT
KING CITY AND GREENFIELD HAVE AS
MUCH OF A NEED FOR OUR PROGRAMS
AND WHEN YOU START TALKING ABOUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I HAVE SO
MANY COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
DESPERATE TO HAVE- ART. LOCATED
IN THEIR DOWNTOWN AREA THEY THEY
REALLY WANT TO BRING PEOPLE IN
AND GET PEOPLE TOGETHER AT THE
IN THE HEART OF SOUL OF THEIR
COMMUNITY SO. I'D LIKE TO SEE-
THERE BE A LITTLE BIT MORE-
DIVERSITY IN TERMS OF THE
COMMUNITIES- THIS IS HEAVY ON
THE COAST. AND AND THERE'S NOT
MUCH MUCH INLAND SO- I'D I'D
HOPEFULLY THIS IS GOING TO COME
BACK WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL. HERE IS THAT. ANYMORE
I'M DONE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ARMS WIDE ONE AT DON'T WANNA. BE
REDUNDANT BUT I TO ECHO THE
SAME. CONCERNS I MEAN I COME
FROM LOS ANGELES AND WHICH IS
LIKE A THIRD OF THE STATE SO THE
FACT THAT THERE'S ONLY ONE-
CULTURAL DISTRICT- IN ALL OF
THAT REGION IS HAS REMAINED
ASTOUNDING FOR ME- FOR AWHILE
AND I AM AN INCREDIBLE SUPPORTER
OF THE ARTS- I GUESS MY ONE.
QUESTION IS- YOU KNOW AID SINCE
THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM THERE
WILL BE SOME MORE DETAIL I'M
ASSUMING THAT WILL BE FLESHED
OUT AND SHARED ABOUT HOW YOU'RE
GOING TO BE PROMOTING. SOME
EQUITY IN THE SELECTION. OF- THE
NEW DISTRICTS BECAUSE I MEAN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY. TO GET SELECTION CRITERIA
CORRECT- SO I GUESS I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU ARE GOING
TO BE DOING THIS TIME THAT WILL
BE DIFFERENT. FROM WHAT YOU DID
LAST TIME- THAT RESULTED IN
THESE FOURTEEN. AND THEN THERE
ISN'T ANYTHING IN HERE THAT
TALKS ABOUT HOW THE FUNDS WILL
BE ALLOCATED BETWEEN EXISTING
AND NEW CULTURAL DISTRICTS SO.
IS THERE ANY INFORMATION ON THAT
. THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WILL
BE EVALUATING AS WE DO OUR FIELD
SCANNED WE- WHERE IT FIRST
COHORT WAS A PILOT IT WAS
UNFUNDED REAR OF LEARNED A LOT
FROM IT IN WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LEARN FROM THAT AND IT IS OUR
GOAL WITH THIS MONEY TO BE ABLE
TO EXTEND IT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. I CAN ADD AND- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE QUESTION WE
HAVE. LEARNED A LOT FROM THE
FIRST COHORT AND AS AND JUST
THAT THAT WAS A- AN UNFUNDED
MANDATE SO WE PUT OUR-
OPERATIONS MONEY INTO AND I JUST
WANTED TO HELP THEM BECOME
DESIGNATED. BY THE STATE AND
ACTUALLY HELPED A LOT OF THE
CULTURE DISTRICTS. SPRINGBOARD
INTO OTHER ACTIVITIES. AND
RECOGNITION IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
BUT IN TERMS OF HOW WE'RE GOING
TO ONE OF THE IDEAS THAT WE HAVE
IN MIND IS IF THIS IS THIS- WE
ARE. ALLOWED TO SPENDING WE PLAN
TO SUPPORT THE CURRENT CULTURAL
DISTRICTS FIRST. THOUGH THEY'VE
DONE WORK THEY'VE BEEN REPORTING
TO US ABOUT HOW THEY'VE BEEN
EXISTING WITH THE LIMITED
FUNDING THAT THEY HAD PRIOR.
HOWEVER THE STATE DESIGNATION
IT'S BEEN VERY BENEFICIAL TO
THEM SO WE WANT TO LOOK AND SEE
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND WHAT HOW
THE FUNDING HAS PARLAYED OTHER
FINDING. AND IDENTIFYING A
FUNDING STRUCTURE FOR THE
CURRENT COHORT THEN WE WANT TO
WORK WITH THE COMMUNITY AND
ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY PANEL TO
DEVELOP THE GRANT PROGRAM- AND
IDENTIFY HOW THAT FUNDING IS
GOING TO OCCUR MORE. SO THAT
IT'S VERY RELEVANT POLITICAL
JUST YOU NEED. WE'RE GONNA HOLD
US OPEN AND WAIT FOR MORE
INFORMATION. NEXT WE WILL GONNA
MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER FORTY
THREE- DRUG INTERDICTION EFFORTS. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I MET THE FIRST TIME THE
DEPUTY ADJUTANT GENERAL OF THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT-
I'M FORTY THREE TALKS ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST FOR A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND OUR
EXISTING. MILITARY DEPARTMENT
KERN ARCONIC SUFFERED A
SUPPORTING THE FOR HIGH
INTENSITY DRUG TRAFFICKING AREAS
ACROSS OUR STATE. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS EFFORT WILL AMPLIFY
THAT BUILDING CAPABILITY AND
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO- DEFEAT
TRANSNATIONAL CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND- IN LARGE
MEASURE UP PUT A SIGNIFICANT
DENT IN THE- IN THE CHALLENGES
OUR STATE FACES RELATIVE TO.
DRUGS LIKE FENTANYL
METHAMPHETAMINE COCAINE HEROIN-
IN THOSE TYPES OF ILLEGAL. DRUGS
AND TO LOOK FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU NOW WILL FROM
FINANCE. THE MEMBER OF OUR
FINANCE NO COMMENTS THIS TIME
BUT WILL BE ON STANDBY FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU L. A.
O. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
ITALY WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE ANALYZED A
TOTAL OF NINE PROPOSALS.
INCLUDING THIS ONE AS PART OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PUBLIC SAFETY
PACKAGE- WE DID RAISE CONCERNS
WITH SEVEN OF THEM AND RECENTLY
RELEASED A REPORT THAT OFFERS A
BROAD FRAMEWORK FOR LEGISLATIVE
DELIBERATION. AS WELL AS OPTIONS
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
WE'RE GONNA FOCUS SPECIFICALLY-
ON THOSE THAT RELATE
SPECIFICALLY TO THIS PROPOSAL.
AND SO SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
THIS ONE WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THIS PROPOSAL MAY NOT BE
STRUCTURED. TO ACHIEVE THE
GOVERNOR'S INSPIRED OUTCOME
UNTIL OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS TO REDUCE
OPIOID OPIOID OVERDOSES. AS WELL
AS CRIMES AND VIOLENCE RELATED
TO THE SMUGGLING AND
DISTRIBUTION OF ILLEGAL DRUGS.
HOWEVER OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT REQUESTS FOR
ASSISTANCE TEND TO INVOLVE THE
TARGETING OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION AND TRAFFICKING
WHICH CAN ALSO BE A REASON WILL
TAKE LIKE ALL BUT IT IS NOT THE
SAME AS- ILLEGAL DRUGS RELATED
LINKS. TO OVERDOSE JUST AS- IF
THE STATE IS INTERESTED IN THAT
GOAL OF REDUCING OVERDOSE DEATHS
THIS PROPOSAL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
CONSTRUCTED. MIGHT NOT BE AN
EFFECTIVE WAY TO DO SO. MORE
BROAD. WHEN THE LEGISLATURE IS
THINKING ABOUT THE ENTIRE PUBLIC
SAFETY PACKAGE WE DO RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DETERMINE
ITS HIGHEST PRIORITY PUBLIC
SAFETY GOALS. SPECIFIED CLEAR
OBJECTIVES TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS AND THEN PROVIDE THE
FUNDING IN A MANNER THAT ENSURES
THAT THOSE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES
ARE ACHIEVED. SO IN TERMS OF
THINKING ABOUT- THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY PUBLIC SAFETY FALLS.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
VARIOUS CRIME RELATED OR FIRE
RELATED CALLS SO FOR EXAMPLE-
WHEN WE DID OUR ANALYSIS DATA
INDICATED THAT THERE HAD BEEN A
NOTABLE INCREASE AND HOMICIDES
AND AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS. I'M A
RECENT INCREASE IN MOTOR VEHICLE
RELATED FAST GROWTH IN HOMICIDE
FIREARM TEST AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN THE SHARE OF
HOMICIDES AGGRAVATED ASSAULTS
AND ROBBERIES THAT INVOLVED
FIRE- ADDITIONALLY AS OF JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEY WERE
STILL NEARLY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
ON THE STATE'S LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO SUBSEQUENTLY
BECAME PROHIBITED. FROM
POSSESSING FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE
THAT CRIME RATES TEND TO VARY BY
REGION AS WELL AS TYPE OF CRIME
SO THIS MEANS THAT WHILE A
PARTICULAR CRIME MAY NOT BE OF
SIGNIFICANCE CONCERNED
STATEWIDE. TARGETING SPECIFIC
TYPES OF CRIME IN THOSE AREAS
WHERE THEY ARE IS TO BE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN COULD ALSO
MERIT LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
FINALLY AS AN ALTERNATIVE GIVEN
ABOUT THE TOTAL CRIME RATE IS
CURRENTLY QUITE LOW RELATIVE TO
HISTORICAL STANDARDS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO CONSIDER
PRIORITIZING PUBLIC SAFETY GOALS
THAT ARE NOT DIRECTLY RELATED TO
REDUCING CRIME. SUCH AS BETTER
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOUSING NEEDS OF INDIVIDUALS
WERE INVOLVED WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THERE ARE OTHER
EXAMPLES AS WELL- WE'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
GOING TO START WITH A VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN. WELL TO LAST COMMENT
THE CRIME RATES. COMPARED TO
HISTORIC ARE QUITE LOW- I TEND
TO DISAGREE WITH YOU THERE NOT
QUITE LOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
GROWING FAST. IN IN THESE
PARTICULAR AREAS PARTICULARLY
NOW THAT IS NOT MY POINT. I'M
ALL FOR HAVING ENGAGED THE
NATIONAL GUARD. THAT SHOULD
NEVER BE THEIR PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY THEY HAVE MANY
OTHERS GRAHAM I THINK MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT. BUT THE DEGREE THAT
THE GUARD CAN BE OF ASSISTANCE
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT I'M ALL
FOR THAT. BUT I BELIEVE AS WE-
EXAMINE THIS PROPOSAL- IT NEEDS
TO BE MORE DEFENDER THE REST OF
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO LOOK LIKE
IN WHAT MANNER AND WAIT THEY
WILL COOPERATE WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES. AND WHAT
WILL BE THE RESPONSIBILITY THEIR
IN- I DON'T THINK THAT THEY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO BE ARRESTING
AND- A PROSECUTING. SO WHAT WILL
BE THAT- THAT SUPPORT. THE VOTE
I'M JUST REQUESTING THE LIVE.
FIND MERIT IN THE PROPOSAL I
COULD GET A LITTLE BIT MORE BE
ON THE PHONE IF YOU. THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR SENATOR RON WELL I
JUST WANT TO SAY I'VE MAYBE THE-
PROPOSAL'S MIS TITLED THE-
DEALING WITH CANNABIS IN ANOTHER
SETTING- AND UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE HAVE A VARIETY OF PROBLEMS
WITH THE WAY THE- CANNABIS
PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED AND
CONTINUES TO BE- OPERATING- WE
CERTAINLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH.
THE ILLEGAL. UNAUTHORIZED TO
CANADA'S CANNABIS. OPERATION AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE-
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT-
AND THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT THAT IS CAN ASSIST US
IN CRACKING DOWN ON. THIS
ILLEGAL ENTERPRISES WE WORK
OTHER ASPECTS OF THE CANNABIS-
SITUATION IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
THAT WOULD BE VALUABLE SO IF WE
NEED TO RE TITLE THIS I'M IN
FAVOR OF THAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE PROPOSAL IS BROUGHT FORWARD
. YEAH THANK YOU SENATOR AUTHOR
COPYRIGHT. YES THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL FORWARD I A. M. I HAVE
TO AGREE WITH SENATOR ROSS I
THINK YOU MEAN IT MAY BE JUST AN
ISSUE I THOUGHT LET ME JUST SAY
THAT. THAT- MY THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY PUBLIC SAFETY HAVE
BEEN TWO FOLD ONE IS. THE ISSUE
OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS CULTIVATION
AND TRAFFICKING WHICH THEN LEADS
TO. HAVE BECOME MUCH MORE.
SOPHISTICATED CRIMINAL
ENTERPRISE IT'S DOING THIS KIND
OF- AND GROWING- SO THAT'S ONE
AND ALSO THE- THE USE OF
FIREARMS TO COMMIT. HIS CRIMES
AND- THAT SEEMS TO BE- IN
SPECIFIC COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR AND SO. ANY HELP THAT
WE CAN GIVE A LOCAL. ON IT EVERY
SENSE OF THE MAJORITY OF MY
DISTRICT- COMMUNITIES ARE. ROLE
IN FAIRLY ISOLATED IN OUR- ARE-
PATROLLED BY THE SHERIFF- THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT GETTING THEIR
AFTER THE FACT AND SIGNIFICANTLY
LATER AFTER THE FACT SO ANY
ASSISTANCE THAT. THEY CAN BE
PROVIDED- FROM THE STATE ON THIS
IS- IS REALLY I THINK-
APPRECIATED SO. I'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL AND MAYBE- INCLUDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE LOCALS. TO
TRY TO STOP SOME OF THE DRUG
TRAFFICKING THAT THEN IS
BRINGING THE GUNS AND- THE
WEAPONS AND THAT. ASSAULTS THAT
ARE HAPPENING AS WELL. THANK YOU
YEAH. THAT'S IT SENATOR RON.
WELL THANK YOU MANAGER JUST ONE
MORE QUICK COMMENT I CAN'T
RESIST- SINCE THE PROHIBITED
PERSONS LIST WAS- MENTIONED IN.
I THINK THE ALEJO'S COMMENT. A
SINCE I ARRIVED IN THIS
COMMITTEE IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
AND I WAS. HERE FOR SIX YEARS
BEFORE I TOOK MY SABBATICAL
SABBATICAL- I'VE ASK EVERY YEAR.
IN THE HERE AND ELSEWHERE. THE
PROHIBITED PERSONS LIST IS
CONSIST OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROHIBITED FROM POSSESSING
FIREARMS. BECAUSE OF CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY AND A CRIMINAL
CONVICTION AND PERHAPS FOR SOME
OTHER REASONS AND I HAVE NEVER
UNDERSTOOD WHY AT THE TIME OF
THE SENTENCING. WE ARE NOT
PICKING UP THOSE FIREARMS. AND
INSTEAD WE ALLOW PEOPLE TO GO
OUT SERVE THEIR SENTENCES COME
BACK PICK UP THEIR FIREARMS AND
DO WHATEVER THEY NEED TO DO. AND
I'M JUST MAKING THIS COMMENT FOR
THOSE IN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THOSE IN THE L. A. O. IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. PERHAPS
AT SOME POINT WE CAN HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND I'LL BET THAT
THE COST OF PICKING UP THE
FIREARM FIREARMS AT THE
COURTHOUSE AT THE TIME OF
SENTENCING IS LESS THAN THE
MONEY. WE SPEND SENDING PEOPLE
CHASING ALL OVER THE STATE
TRYING TO FIND PEOPLE WHO DON'T
WANT TO BE FOUND WITH GUNS THAT
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU AND YOU
HAVE. STARTED SOMETHING. BY
THEIR- OWN A SOURCE POINT- WITH
. AND THE ARMS HAVE A PERSON
ISSUE IS ONE THAT WE ALSO MUST
DEAL WITH WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE THAT'S A LONG
LONG STANDING. HUGE PROBLEM THAT
HAS NOT BEEN RESOLVED SO. WE'VE
GOT TO MOVE ON SEVERAL FRONTS IN
THAT REGARD AND CERTAINLY IN
SYMPATHY WITH. THANK YOU FOR
THAT THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT. IF I IF I
MIGHT USE- IN TERMS OF THIS IS
IN ITALY WITH THE L. A. L. JUST
BECAUSE THE RESPECTIVE SENATORS
HAVE ALL EXPRESSED INTEREST
RELATED TO THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD EMPHASIZE
IN TERMS OF THINKING ABOUT YOUR
PRIORITIES- WHEN THEY HEARD THE
ISSUE ITEM RELATED TO ONE OF THE
PROPOSALS IN THE PACKAGE WHICH
WAS FOR A GUN BUYBACK PROGRAM.
WE HAD RAISED SOME CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROGRAM BUT WE ARE ALSO
OFFERED A COUPLE OF OPTIONS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY TIED- TO THE ARMED
AND PROHIBITED LEFT FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION AND
JUST BRIEFLY SO THAT YOU'RE
AWARE OF IT. I'M SINCE THERE IS
BEST INTEREST I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THEM FOR YOU WHICH IS
ONE OPTION WAS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAD PROVIDE
PREVIOUSLY AS PART OF LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET. PROVIDED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME FOR
DOJ'S DONE VIOLENCE REDUCTION
PROGRAM WHICH PROVIDED NEED TO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S THE WHOLE
PRODUCE THAT LIST. BY SEIZING
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITIONS FROM
THEM AS OF THAT- THE LET. COULD
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO THE
PROGRAM AND ALSO MAKE OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT LAKE CITY POLICE
ALSO AVAILABLE FOR THE GRANT
FUNDING. DIRECTLY RELATED TO
SENATOR ROCKS COMMENTS- ANOTHER
OPTION THAT WE- RECOMMEND THAT
WE RECOMMEND IT FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION. IS IT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO LIMIT THE
GROWTH OF THE LAST- IT COULD
MAKE SENSE TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT FIREARMS ARE RELINQUISH. AT
THE TIME INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING
THROUGH THOSE COURT PROCEEDINGS
THAT ULTIMATELY PROHIBIT THEM
FROM OWNING THEM. SO I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION WAS AVAILABLE TO
THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOUNG.
PERFECT THERE WE GO WELL AT THE
RISK OF SOUNDING REDUNDANT- YOU
KNOW I TO I'M HOPING THAT. WHEN
THIS COMES BACK BEFORE US THAT
THERE'S A LITTLE MORE MEAT ON
THE BONES- AND HOPEFULLY TO
DELINEATE YOU KNOW FUNDING THAT
IS REQUESTED THAT CAN HELP IN
THE COORDINATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. TO HELP YOU WITH SOME
OF THE OUTCOMES THAT YOU'RE
HOPING TO SEE COME TO FRUITION I
TO SORT OF QUESTION ALL THE TIME
IS SPENT IN THE CANNABIS SPACE
BECAUSE IT IS LEGAL AND ONE OF
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
I'VE ACTUALLY HEARD. ABOUT SORT
OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY AS IT
RELATES TO CANNABIS IS WATER
FAST- AND BUT I AM A SUSPECTING
THAT- THAT'S NOT INCORPORATED IN
IN THIS PROPOSAL- AND ALSO HOW
THE SOME OF THE ILLEGAL
CULTIVATION ACTIVITIES ARE
CONNECTED WITH INTERNATIONAL
CARTELS WHO ARE DOING OTHER
THINGS. SOME OF IT IS-
TRAFFICKING OF WEAPONS- AND YOU
KNOW IF YOU WOULD PROBABLY BE
WISE TO KIND OF THINK- A LITTLE
BIT MORE- ABOUT. HOW TO. IMPACT
THE FEDERAL ISSUE WHICH I SEE IS
ALSO LISTED IN HERE BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S TAKING UP A
HUGE AMOUNT OF TIME. IN OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEES WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS- EVEN THOUGH IT IS
COMPLICATED BY CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
. ARE THE ADMINISTRATION NOTED
THAT THE PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
OVER SUBSCRIBED SO QUESTION IS
HOW IS CMG GOING TO PRIORITIZE-
WHICH REQUESTS- IT FOCUSES ON.
I'M SURE I THINK- IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT- WE USE THE BEFORE
HIGH INTENSITY DRUG TRAFFICKING
AREAS- IN OUR STATE. WHICH NAY
ARE A- A FUSION SELLER BODY IF
YOU WILL THAT INCLUDES NOT ONLY
STATE FEDERAL LOCAL TRIBAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO SET
PRIORITIES FOR SPECIFIC AREAS
WITHIN OUR OUR STATE AND WE USE-
THOSE HEIGHT IS TO INFORM. HOW
WE- PROVIDE SUPPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT- TO- THAT ARE THIS IS
WHAT WE DO RELATIVE TO CANNABIS
YOU MADE THOSE POINTS. WE SPENT
A LOT OF TIME IN THE NATIONAL
STATE FORCE ACROSS OUR STATE.
WHERE YOU HAVE- INDUSTRIAL SIZED
CARTEL SPONSORED ILLEGAL OUTDOOR
CANNABIS GROWS- THAT AS YOU
MENTIONED NOT ONLY DESTROY THE
ECOLOGY OF OUR GREAT STATE BUT
ALSO STEAL WATER I THINK IT
TAKES A POINT FIVE GALLONS OF
WATER A DAY KEEP AN OUTDOOR
CANNABIS PLANT AND ILLEGAL
OUTDOOR CANNABIS PLANT GOING
SHOULD YOU CAN IMAGINE IN THE
MEGA DROUGHT THAT WE ARE IN NOW.
ALL THAT WATER BEING DIVERTED TO
SHOOT ILLEGAL INDUSTRIAL SIZE
CARTEL GROUPS AND W'RE VERY
SENSITIVE TO THAT WE SPENT AN
EXCEPTIONAL AMOUNT OF TIME.
WORKING ON ON THAT CHALLENGE
YOUR POINT ABOUT THAT MOMENT AND
IN COCAINE AND OTHERS WE'VE SEEN
UP WE'VE SUPPORTED SEIZURES OVER
LAST YEAR SO. FROM TWENTY TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE- ARE SUPPORTS TWO
PHENYL SEIZURES HAVE GONE UP TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT PERCENT. SO THE WORK THAT
WE CAN DO RELATIVE TO THIS- THIS
REQUEST WILL ONLY. EXPAND OUR
CAPABILITY TO GET MORE OF THOSE. ILLEGAL DRUGS OFF THE STREET.
THANK THANK YOU- WE'RE GONNA
HOLD US OVER AND ON NOW TO I
NUMBER FORTY FOUR ENHANCING AND
EXPANDING FIRE CREWS TASK FORCE
RATTLESNAKE WHAT AN UNFORTUNATE
NAME. FOR SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
LIKE SNAKES. YEAH I DON'T LIKE
SNAKES EITHER BUT- THAT THE
SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN THAT- DO THE
WORK THOUGHT IT WAS APPROPRIATE
AND SO THEY'RE DOING THE WORK
THEY GET TO NAME THE TASK.
THAT'S TRUE. SO SO THIS REQUEST
IS THAT PER FIFTEENS DIRECT DO
POSITIONS AT THIRTY NINE POINT
NINE ONE YEAR. OF FORTY THREE
POINT ONE ON GOING. AND WHAT
THIS IS GOING TO DO IS
ESSENTIALLY GOING TO CONVERT-
OUR OUR FUELS MANAGEMENT TEAMS
THAT KIDS ARE OUT- CLEARING THE-
COMBUSTIBLE FUELS ACROSS OUR
STATE LANDS. IT'S GOING TO
CONVERT- THAT WORK WHICH IS
CURRENTLY BEING DONE- AND BEING
FUNDED BY- FEMA. CHU AT THE
STATE FUNDING ONGOING STATE
FUNDING. AT THE EXPECT THE- THE
FEDERAL FUNDING TO EXPIRE. AT
THE END OF OUR CURRENT STATE
FISCAL YEAR THIRTY THIRTY JAN.
AND THAT SAID THAT'S WHY WE'RE
COMING TO YOU WITH THIS REQUEST
SO GIVE US ESSENTIALLY FOURTEEN.
TYPE ONE- WILDLAND FIREFIGHTING
INCREASE THAT NOT ONLY WILL DO
FEELS MANAGEMENT. BUT ALSO
SUPPORT CAL FIRE AND I SUPPORT
IT ALSO THAT THIS- THAT THE
FOLKS THAT ARE DOING THIS WORK
ON OUR BEHALF OR DOING IT- UNDER
THE SUPERVISION AUSPICES OF CAL
FIRE. GREAT FORTY YOUR QUESTIONS
PERFECT OKAY. WEBER GOVERNMENT
FINANCES THAT L. A. L. THE
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- IS SO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS TO
WITH AN EXPANDING AND THE AND
CONTINUING THE TASK FORCE'S
RATTLESNAKE CREATED JUST FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT MADAM
CHAIR THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED-
ONE TIME FUNDING FOR CAN CRUISE
ON A SEASONAL BASIS- AND THEN
FEDERAL FUNDING CAME AND NOT
ALLOW THAT SORT OF SUPPLANTED
THE STATE FINDS AND ALLOW. IT
TASK FORCE ROSS NAY CREASE TO
EXPAND- AS WELL AS CONTINUING
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD FURTHER
EXPAND TO A TOTAL OF FOURTEEN
HAND CHRIS WITH NO DAMAGE AND WE
DON'T HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THAT
BUT WHEN AS WAS NOTED AND- HOW
FIRE WILL BE AND THE SUPPORTING
AND SUPERVISING THESE CRASHES.
THE CURRENT FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED WAS ACTUALLY PROVIDED A
CAL FIRE AND DOWNTURN INTER
AGENCY AGREEMENT UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL FUNDING WOULD GO
DIRECTLY TO THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT ON AN ONGOING BASIS
HOWEVER THERE WILL BE COSTS ON
THE CAL FIRE SIDE ON IN ORDER TO
SUPPORT AND SUPERVISE THESE
CHRIS. THAT COSTS FOR
CALIFORNICA BUDGET IN A PROPOSAL
FOR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR CAL FIRE WHERE THEY HAVE NOT
GIVEN- I. T. HELP PROPOSAL TO
THE LEGISLATURE I'M AND THIS IS
SORT OF PART OF THAT LARGER
WILDFIRE RESPONSE PACKAGE AS
WELL ALL OF THAT HAS BEEN HEARD
ON IN OTHER SUB COMMITTEES AND
SO WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT YOU
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN AND CONSIDER
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF YOUR
OVERALL PRIORITIES FOR WHAT.
YOUR RESPONSE- AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE THAT YOU HAVE MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION ON THE CAL FIRE
PIECE OF THE PROPOSAL TO
UNDERSTAND THE FULL COST OF
SUPPORTING THESE FOURTEEN CREE
IS ON AN ONGOING BASIS HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS GREAT THANK
YOU- SO NOW I'M GONNA TURN IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I'M GONNA START ONCE AGAIN
WITH MY VICE CHAIR SENATOR
NIELSEN. OKAY GREAT SENATOR ROB
. THE NEW CABALLERO. JUST A
QUICK- IT IT'S BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT CAL FIRE- FUNDING. IN
ADDITION IN. ALONG WITH THIS
TELL ME WHAT. IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE WILL BE DOUBLE SUPERVISION
ONE FROM THE- MILITARY
DEPARTMENT AND THEN ALSO FROM
FROM A CAL FIRE. THAT MAY BE
OPERATIONALLY HOW YOU WE
NORMALLY OPERATE- SO- I
APOLOGIZE FOR MY IGNORANCE. I
KNOW SENATOR THAT THAT YOUR YOUR
SPOT ON IT SO CAL FIRE DATE WITH
THE SUPERVISOR ESSENTIALLY TELL
OUR OUR SOLDIERS AND AIRMEN YOU
KNOW WHERE TO GO WHAT TO DO HOW
TO DO IT THEY PROVIDE THE
TACTICAL EXECUTION OF IT- ALONG
THOSE LINES. SINCE WE HAVE WOULD
HAVE YOU KNOW A CLUSTER OF FOUR
HUNDRED FOLKS- OUT IN THE FIELD
IT REQUIRES- CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
OVERHEAD TO ENSURE THAT THE
UNIQUE- PERSONAL REQUIREMENTS
HEY ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT
BACK IN SUPPORT- VEHICLES IF YOU
WILL ALL THE EQUIPMENT- IS
MANAGED APPROPRIATELY THAT'S
WITH THE POSITIONS FOR THE
MILITARY DEPARTMENT THE ACTUAL
TACTICAL EXECUTION IS SUPERVISED
BY. BY CAL FIRE BUT WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT OUR SOLDIERS NEAR MY
CROPS YOU'LL- FIND IT THANK YOU
SO MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT. THANK
YOU ARE YOU KNOW I HAVEA
QUESTION I THINK FOR L. A. WE'VE
HEARD SOME- WE'VE HEARD SOME
CONCERNS FROM COUNTIES AT THIS
PROPOSAL MAY VIOLATE PROP ONE
EIGHTY- IS THAT TRUE. ARE WE ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE NOT HEARD THAT
FROM COUNTY BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO
AND- CIRCLE BACK WITH YOU IN
YOUR OFFICE AND I WOULD. GET
SOME MORE INFORMATION FOR YOU ON
THAT. OKAY GREAT I DON'T OFTEN
ANSWERS ANYTHING. NICE TO
MILLION ARE THAT BUT ALL OF THE
FACTS WERE FOLKS OKAY GREAT.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE OVER
TO ISSUE NUMBER FORTY FIVE.
INSUFFICIENT EDUCATION REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUN BACK FILLS. AND
WHO DO WE HAVE. THE NEW RIDLEY
THOMAS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND I'LL BE PRESENTED
THIS ITEM PERFECT. SO AT A HIGH
LEVEL THIS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DOES TWO THINGS IT CREATES A
MORE EFFICIENT PROCESS FOR
COUNTIES TO SUBMIT CLAIMS THERE
WAS THE TIME BACK THOSE FINANCES
MISSION ERA. AND ALSO ADDRESSES
AN ISSUE IN WHICH SCHOOLS ARE
LOSING OUT ON ABOUT A QUARTER
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPERTY TAX
REVENUEPER YEAR WHILE PROVIDING
A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS TO
ENSURE CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
REIMBURSED FOR THE YELLOW BOX.
SO BEFORE I GET INTO THE
SPECIFICS OF THE PROPOSAL I'M
GOING TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND ON THE THREE
DRIVING FACTORS BEHIND THIS
EACH. THE FIRST IS THE ENGINE.
REVENUE AUGMENTATION FONG OR THE
EGRESS. YOU ARE STATUES WERE
ENACTED IN THE EARLY NINETIES.
THIS YEAR PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
FROM CITIES COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS THE CAKE AND FOURTEEN
SCHOOLS. THERE IS ANY REFERENCE
EACH COUNTY IN EUROPE CAN ONLY
GO TO THE NON BASIC EIGHT
SCHOOLS. THE SECOND FACTOR IS
THAT I AM IN BETWEEN THE VEHICLE
LICENSE FEES WHILE ON THE VLF
SWAP IN HIS VISION THE REST. IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE THE VEHICLE
LICENSE FEE RATE WAS REDUCED
FROM 2% TWO POINT SIX FIVE
PERCENT. THE BACK FEEL THAT LOST
REVENUE FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES.
STATUTE WAS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR TO REITERATE
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE REVENUE
FROM E. REF. BACK TO THE CITIES
AND TOWNS. THIS IS CALLED THE
BLS WALL. IF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
MONEY IN THE RAF TO PAY FOR THE
BILL THAT'S WHAT. THE DIFFERENCE
IS MADE UP BY SHIP IN PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE. FROM NON BASIC
EIGHT SCHOOLS THE DISEASE
ACCOUNTS. IF THERE STILL ISN'T
ENOUGH REVENUE FOR THE MEAL OF
SWAP AFTER SHIPPING IS REVENUE
FROM THE SCHOOLS. INSUFFICIENTLY
RECORDS. THERE'S IMPORTANT THING
KEEP IN MY- AND HOW DOES REVENUE
JUST THANKS. BY WHO FUNDING. THE
STATE BANK THE SHOW RHODE
HUNDRED. TWO THREE F. NINETY
EIGHT. HOWEVER I TEST ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS NINETY EIGHT. WHICH IS
BEEN OPERATIVE SINCE EIGHTEEN
MY- AND BE OFFERED TO FOR THE-
FUTURE. THAT SHIFT DEPARTMENT
SIX REVENUE IS NOT BACK FEEL
WHILE STATE SO WAS THE REVENUE
LOSS WITH THE SCHOOL. THE LAST
IS A SAY READ. EXCESS RENTAL
CARS WHEN YOU. CANNOT BE SLOWLY
. WITH BECAUSE THERE ARE TOO
MANY BASIC A SCHOOLS. THANKS AS
HE WRAPPED HIS RETURN TO THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES. UNDER
CURRENT LAW EXISTS YEAR ROUND
CANNOT BE COUNTY FORCE THE BLS
WALK PAID. ALL RIGHT AND I WILL
GET INTO THE PROPOSED. THIS ONE
IS TWELVE THIRTEEN THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED THIRTY THREE MILLION AS
ADDITION HERE AFFECTS FEELS
ANOTHER NINETY SIX MILLION IS
PROPOSALS TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND I JUST KNOW THAT THESE
BACK FEELS ARE NOT REQUIRED BY
LAW. CURRENTLY CLAIMS ARE PAID
TWO YEARS IN ARREARS. WHICH
MEANS THE COUNTIES IN CURRENTLY
INSUFFICIENT YOU REVEREND ONE
FISCAL YEAR AND THEN I RECEIVE A
BACK FEEL TO FISCAL YEARS LATER.
THIS KILEY BILL LANGUAGE CREATES
A FRAMEWORK FOR COUNTIES TO BE
PAID WITHIN THE YEAR AND WISH TO
INSUFFICIENT YOU WRAP WILL
OCCUR. IT ALSO CREATES A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
FULMINATE THE NEED FOR A ONE
TIME BUDGET APPROPRIATIONS EVERY
YEAR AND TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY
AROUND THE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
THIS PURPOSE. FINALLY THIS
TROUBLING REMAINS. TO REQUIRE X.
THIS YEAR. TO THE LOS TO BE ABLE
TO SWAP COSTS WHICH- WAS RESULT
IN MORE. FOR SCHOOLS. THAT FAIL
BE LESS PROPERTY TAXES ABOUT
WHERE BUT- BASIC. EIGHT THIS
COULD MY PRESENCE I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE HUGHES HUMOR ME AND WE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY. THAT MIGHT
. FINANCE. OH SORRY THAT'S RIGHT
YOU KNOW HOW CITY WHEN I WAS A
TASK THAT WAS ATTACHED NUMBER
HERE FROM ALEJO BECAUSE NORMALLY
YOU GUYS ARE THE ONES SORRY MY
BAD MISS TIFFANY HELLO.
AFTERNOON NO THAT'S MORE OR LESS
WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE.
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES A PROCESS TO
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE STATE
GENERAL FUND TO BACK THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHEN THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT IRAQ TO ADDRESS THE
BLS WALK. ADDITIONALLY IF YOU
MENTION PROPOSES TO OFFSET THE
STATE GENERAL FUND BACK THE LOOK
ACCESS THE RAF BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
ULTIMATELY IT IS UNIQUE HAVE
BOTH INSUFFICIENT IRAQ TO
ADDRESS THE BLS SPOT AND
AXISDIRECT AFTER THE STATE SHARE
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE IT'S MATT.
ACCESS IRAQI A SPECIAL FISCAL
ALLOWANCE CURRENTLY BENEFITS
FIVE COUNTIES. AND EXIST BECAUSE
THEIR PROPERTY TAX REVENUE IS
VERY HIGH RELATIVE TO THE
STATUTORY FUNDING REQUIREMENTS
FOR THEIR SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOR COUNTIES WITHOUT
EXCESS EVEN AFTER THE FACT-
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD. CONSISTENT HIGHER LEE A
STATE GENERAL FUND. IN OF
PROPOSED BY THE END OF THE
MINUTE. MAKES AS A PROVIDES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REIMBURSEMENTS
MORE QUICKLY THAN THE CURRENT
PROCESS AND STREAMLINES THE
PROCESS FOR CLEANING A BACK
FILL. UNDER CURRENT PRACTICE
STATE GENERAL FUND IS PROVIDED
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGH AN
ANNUAL BUDGET ACT ON A ONE TIME
BASIS. THE COVER IN DIVISION II
RAF THE BACKFILL IS PROVIDED IN
ARREARS SHORTFALL HAVE BEEN
RELATIVELY LOW IN PAST YEARS THE
GROWING PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
COMBINED WITH MORE BASIC IT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. AS INCREASE
EFFICIENCIES AND PRODUCTION
SYSTEM CONTINUED GROWTH IN THE
SHORT. I TO IN THE BACK MEETING
WORK HAVE A LOOK GOVERNMENT TO
MANAGE. AT THE BACK FILAMENTS
GROW SINCE THE ELECTION
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF GENERAL
PURPOSE LOCAL REVENUE. FIND THE
PROPOSED TO BE OUT MAKES A STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE RESPONSIBLE
FOR REVIEWING AND APPROVING AS
WELL AS AUDITING CLAIMS FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
INSUFFICIENT IRAQ. UNDER THE
CURRENT PROCESS DO YOU HAVE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING
CLAIMS. SCO DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY CURRENTLY- OR THAT SORT
OF POLICY EXPERTISE TO REVIEW
AND APPROVE YOUR ROTH CLAIMS.
AND IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR WHETHER IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE TO DEVELOP
THIS EXPERTISE AND CAPACITY AND
THAT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER THEY ARE
AS TO THE APPROPRIATE DEPARTMENT
TO HAVE THAT ROLE. TYPICALLY I
FEEL MAKES PAYMENTS TO COUNTIES
BASED ON DIRECTION PROVIDED TO
THEM BY OTHER STATE ENTITIES
THAT ADMINISTER RELEVANT
PROGRAMS. WE ARE CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT THE ENTITY WITH
THE BEST POSITION TRIBUNE
APPROVE THESE CLAIMS SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE WISH TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH A PROPOSAL PROVIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND I'M GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE AND I START
WITH MY. PRESSURE SENATOR NELSON
. JUST A CAUTION THIS IS
SENSITIVE AREA GO BACK. SEVERAL
YEARS. AND WE'VE RECEIVED OFTEN
FROM OF C. SACK FROM THE ROOT
THE LEADER CITY URBAN COUNTIES
GENERAL COUNTY RIGHT. AS WELL SO
IT'S A BROAD BASE OF- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL IN HOW WE ANALYZE
THIS. THAT THAT'S ALL ALL RIGHT
SO HER RUN. WELL AT THE RISK OF
ASKING A QUESTION TO GET AND
GETTING AN ANSWER WON'T
UNDERSTAND LET ME JUST OF. THE
ANALYSIS NOTES SEVERAL COUNTIES
AND CITIES I SUPPOSE THAT'S WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE WAS REFERRING TO
OPPOSE A PROVISION REQUIRING
EXCESS YOU REF REVENUES TO FIRST
BACK FILL. THE VLF INSUFFICIENCY
CAN SOMEONE EXPLAIN THAT ONE TO
ME WHY. I CAN TAKE A SHOT AT
THAT RESULTS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. UNDER CURRENT LAW IN IN
IN THE COUNTY. THE FIRST DRAW TO
REIMBURSE THE CITY OR COUNTY OR
THEIR- VEHICLE LICENSE FEES
WHILE REVENUES THE REVENUES A
LOSS OF THE VEHICLE LICENSE FEE
WAS REDUCED. RECALL THAT
REIMBURSEMENT MECHANISM THE BLS
LAW. YOUR FIRST DRAW FOR THE
REAL BILL OF SWAP IS THE RAF.
AND THEIR SECURITY INTERESTS
CURRENT LAW THAT SAYS. IF YOU
HAVE SO MANY BASIC EIGHT SCHOOLS
WHICH ARE INELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
THE ROUTE IF YOU HAVE SO MANY
BASIC EIGHT SCHOOLS IN YOUR
COUNTY. BASICALLY IT SCHOOLS CAN
GET HE ROUTE SO THAT MONEY JUST
COMES BACK FROM THE RAF
AUTOMATICALLY TO THE DONOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES. CURRENT LAW
SAYS THAT MONEY THAT IS RETURNED
ON THE NATURAL SO TO SPEAK
BECAUSE IT CANNOT BE ABSORBED BY
BASIC AND SCHOOLS DOES NOT COUNT
TOWARDS ALL SITTING HERE PLS
WALK COSTS FOR THE CITY AND
COUNTY. AND EVERY OTHER COUNTY
THE MONEY THAT COMES FROM THE
RAF DOES COUNT TOWARDS THAT BUT
IT DOESN'T IN THESE. ACCESS IRAQ
COUNTIES WHICH THERE ARE FIVE.
AND OUR TRAILER BILL SEEKS TO
ADDRESS THE ANOMALY. AND THE
THOUGHT IS THAT THEY WOULD GET.
THAT THOSE COUNTIES AND BASS.
THOSE BASIC AID COUNTIES. OR
BASIC KIDS SCHOOLS COUNTIES THAT
HAVE BASE HIT SCHOOLS CITIES AND
COUNTIES WOULD GET MORE MONEY
BECAUSE THEY GET BOTH A GENERAL
FUND AND THE E. RO. WELL WE
THINK THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
NOW BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IS
LET'S LET'S SAY THERE'S A
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND ACCESS THE
RAPIDS BILLS BACK TO OF. THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES. THAT ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IS NOT COUNT
TOWARDS YOUR BLS WALK OSTRACISM
BUT INSTEAD HAPPENS THE COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLER GO TO THE-
NON BASIC AID SCHOOLS WHICH TO
RECEIVE STATE GENERAL FUND. AND
TAKES FROM THEM ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND GIVES OUT TO THE
SCHOOLS- AND GIVE THAT TO THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO REIMBURSE
ARE REALISTS LAW. SO IN ESSENCE
WHAT'S HAPPENING THESE ACCESS
NEARMAP COUNTIES IS PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE IS BEING TAKEN FROM THE
NON BASIC EIGHT SCHOOLS. TO
REIMBURSE THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES. AND UNDER TEST ONE OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
ACTUALLY HAS A VERY ARTIFACT AND
WHAT IT DOES IS IT WINDS UP IN
EVERY SCHOOL IN THE STATE.
LOSING MONEY BECAUSE OF THAT.
BECAUSE UNDER TEST ONE. THERE'S
A FIXED PART OF ABOUT 38% OF THE
STATE GENERAL FUND IT GOES TO
THE SCHOOLS. AND SO WHAT HAPPENS
IS GOING BACK TO MY EXAMPLE THAT
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS IS TAKEN
FROM THE SCHOOLS. AND GIVEN TO
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES. THAT
ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS BACK FIELD
FROM THAT X. HOT OF. 38% OF
GENERAL FUND FOR THEIR BALLOTS.
AND SO THAT HUNDRED DOLLARS
COMES OUT OF THE POT AND GOES TO
THE COUNTY SCHOOLS IN THAT
COUNTY. AND THAT MEANS EVERY
OTHER SCHOOL IN THE STATE HAS
LOST ACCESS THAT ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. THANK YOU ANOTHER. YOU
SAID IT'S A HAS A STATEWIDE
AFFECTED WERE SEEKING TO
ADDRESS. WELL I APOLOGIZE FOR
ASKING THAT QUESTION BUT THANK
pSTICKING AROUND LONG ENOUGH IS
YOU UNDERSTAND ALL OF THIS
BECAUSE IT'S LIKE I REMEMBER.
HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT YEAR
AFTER THE VLF FOR THE TRIPLE
FLIP AND ALL THIS STUFF AND I
JUST KEPT SAYING DON'T DO IT- IS
THERE A WAY FOR US TO FIX THIS
GOING FORWARD. SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO GO TO THESE- GYMNASTICS
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
FURTHER YOU GET AWAY FROM. FROM
THE- THE CRAZINESSOF THE
NINETIES AND THE SHIFTING OF
FUNDS FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
THE STATE AND FROM COUNTIES TO
CITIES IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND
WHY WE'RE STILL DOING THIS. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
EXPLANATION BY THE WAY BECAUSE I
THINK IT WAS MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE BUT IT IT'S- JUST SEEMS TO
ME LIKE WE OUGHT TO DO A SIMPLER
PROCESS. AND I KNOW THAT THEN
SOMEBODY'S SOMEBODY'S- LOSES
SOMETHING IN THE BUDGET BUT IS
THERE A WAY FOR US TO DEAL WITH
THIS. AND PART OF IT IS THE
DRIVES ME CRAZY IS WE MADE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS ARE WE ASK. COUNTIES
WAY BACK IN THE DAY. TIM TO MAKE
AN ELECTION. TO RECEIVE MONEY
BASED ON THINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING IN THE COUNTY AT THAT
TIME. AND THOSE THINGS ARE NO
LONGERAPPLICABLE AND YET
THEY'RE STUCK MY FAMILY TO
COUNTY GETS A LOT LESS. THAN
THEY ARE REALLY ENTITLED TO
BECAUSE OF DECISIONS THEY MADE
EARLY. EARLY ON IN IN- IN THEIR
BUDGETING PROCESS. SO I HEAR
REPEATEDLY THAT THEY'RE STILL
UNDER FOR UNDERFUNDED IS
COMPARED TO OTHER COUNTIES. E.
L. F. UNDER PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. THE AMOUNT OF PROPERTY
TAX REVENUE TO GET
DISPROPORTIONATE TO WHAT YOU'RE
GETTING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY.
EIGHT OR SEVENTY NINE SO IF
YOU'RE A COUNTY THAT DIDN'T LEVY
HIGH PROPERTY TAX YOU'RE STILL
LIVING WITH THE REPLICATIONS OF
THAT TO THE STATE OF UPSTREAM.
RIGHT NO PLANS TO KIND OF FIX
THIS. WELL I YEAH I THINK THAT
TO ADDRESS PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
WOULD. YEAH IT CREATES SO MANY
WINNERS AND LOSERS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT I THINK COULD BE
EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT THE RESULT
IN MASSIVE PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
SHIFTS BETWEEN A MULTITUDE OF
LOCAL AGENCIES IN EACH COUNTY.
GOT IT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT I DIDN'T REALIZE WE HAD TO
GO BACK TO PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
. YEAH YOU JUST SAY IT AND
PEOPLE START TO ADD. THAT'S ALL
I GOT MEDICARE. THAT'S THE WAY
IT ENDED UP FROM THIRTEEN
PERCENT IT ALL DOWN HI I HAVE I
HAVE NO QUESTIONS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE ALL BEEN ASKED BUT WE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT I INCORRECTLY ASKED ABOUT
THE VIOLATION OF PROP ONE EIGHTY
TWO THE LAST PANEL AND IT WAS
ACTUALLY FOR THIS PANEL BUT THAT
GOT IT DRESSED IN THE QUESTIONS
THAT WERE ASKED BY SENATOR ROB-
SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
THE NEXT ISSUE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SIX THE COW KIDS. SAVINGS
ACCOUNT. I'M GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THAT RELY
CHÁVEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA KIDS
INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPING
DEVELOPMENTS SAVINGS PROGRAM
COCKETTES. APART BUT DISSIPATION
NOTIFICATION AND MARKETING
COSTS. AT THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
MILLION I'M GOING TO GENERAL
FUND. BUT FINANCIAL LITERACY
OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT WILL
INFORM FAMILIES OF THE LONG TERM
BENEFITS OF SAVINGS. ASSOCIATED
WITH THE COCKETTES PROGRAM. AND
TO THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND I'M
GOING TO GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
TO ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR THE
COPIES FROM HER. I THINK AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. NOW LIVE IN WITH THE
SCHOLARSHIP MESSED AND BOARD-
WE'RE WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE MAIN HOUSE
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU MISTER
WHITE MAN. IS THE OIL ON. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF THEY
CAN RELIGIOUSLY ANALYST'S OFFICE
. WE DON'T CONCERNS REGARDING
THE PROPOSED TO POSITIONS AND
ASSOCIATED FUNDING. WE DIDN'T
RAISE TWO ISSUES REGARDING THAT
MARKETING OUTREACH PROPOSALS.
YOU RELEASED A COORDINATION
ACROSS PROPOSALS. THERE IS SOME
OVERLAP IN THE OBJECTIVES OF THE
PEOPLE'S SCHOOLS WITH THE
PARTICIPANT NOTIFICATIONS AND
MARKETING CAMPAIGN INTENDED TO
NOTIFY STUDENTS AND FAMILIES OF
HEALTH THE COUNTS AND FINANCIAL
LITERACY AVERAGE PROPOSAL
INTENDED TO INFORM STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES OF THE BENEFITS.
WE THINK THERE'S OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO GET ACTUALLY CONSOLIDATE
THESE PROPOSALS IN ORDER TO SEND
MORE COORDINATED MESSAGE TO
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES. AS WELL
AS REDUCE THE POTENTIAL FOR
DUPLICATION ACROSS THESE AFTER.
CONDITIONALLY REYES SPECIFIC TO
THE FINANCIAL LITERACY OUTREACH
FUNDS. ADMINISTRATION IS
PROVIDED SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW
DISCUSSION BEST WORD MIGHT USE
THESE FUNDS INCLUDING. UPDATING
THE PROGRAM WEBSITE DEVELOPING
INFORMATIONAL MATERIALS
TRANSLATING THIS MATERIAL AND
OTHER UNSPECIFIED FINANCIAL
LITERACY ACTIVITIES. HOWEVER THE
PROPOSED FUNDING AMOUNT FIVE
MILLION IS NOT CONNECTED TO THE
ESTIMATED COST OF THESE
ACTIVITIES. AND WHILE THE
FUNDING IS ONGOING SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES. ONE TIME IN NATURE.
WE RECOMMEND WITHHOLDING ACTION
ON THAT FIVE MILLION ONGOING FOR
FINANCIAL LITERACY OUTREACH AND
REQUESTING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL HELLO CARE ACT IDENTIFIES
THE SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES
DISCUSSION BEST BOARDGAMEGEEK
PROVIDES THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE ACTIVITIES IN THE
DIRECTION OF THIS COST. AND ALSO
IDENTIFIED ANY OPPORTUNITIES TO
POTENTIALLY COORDINATOR
CONSOLIDATE THESE ACTIVITIES.
WITH THE RELATED PARTISAN
NOTIFICATION MARKETING PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU AND HAVE YOU TAKEN
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU AND I'M
GONNA TURN IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN. SENATOR ON. SENATOR
CAREER OKAY- I'M JUST GOING TO
ASK THAT MAYBE FOLKS TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE ELYAS
OFFICE IN TERMS OF AND BETTING-
THE OUR REGION THE FINANCIAL
LITERACY COMPONENTS INTO THIS I.
ALSO GAVE ME MADE ME THINK ABOUT
THE PRIVACY OFFICER PERSONALLY
TALKED ABOUT IN THE BEGINNING
AND THERE WILL BE SOME
INFORMATION I'M SURE THAT
SENSITIVE AS IT RELATES TO.
THESE FAMILIES- BUT THAT'S ME
GETTING IN MY OWN HEAD. IS THERE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WELL HOPEFULLY
ALL RIGHT THAT'S ALL I'M GONNA
SAY THAT THAT'S FOOD FOR THOUGHT
AND SINCE FOR THIS IS A HOLD
OPEN I DON'T WILL LOOK FORWARD
TO SEEING SOMETHING A LITTLE
MORE FLESHED OUT LATER ON. THANK
YOU. WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER. IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO. FOUR SIX TWO. ONCE AGAIN
THE PHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX. TWO ONE SIX
THREE. ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX
TWO. TWO FOUR SIX TWO. DO YOU
CAN TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MY
ANSWER TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE%
PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT KEEP
THEIR REMARKS TO WITHIN ONE
MINUTE. SO IT'S NOT THAT I DON'T
LIKE YOU BUT I JUST WANT
EVERYONE TO HAVE THE ONE MINUTE
TIMELINE. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM SEEING NONE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY. CURRENTLY AT. FIFTEEN VERY GOOD KANSEN YADDA
I'M- MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE. A
LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THERE
ARE. CHECKS FROM CHRISTIANITY
I'LL BE HAPPENSTANCE COUNTY
CALLING TO CONVEY THAT COUNTY
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSED BE
WRAPPED TRAILER BILL UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED TO REMOVE PROVISIONS AT
ONE. I DON'T POST TRAILER BILL
WOULD CHANGE THE CURRENT STATUTE
IN A WAY THAT HARM THEIR COUNTY
DID YOU. ARE USING OUR OWN LOCAL
TAX REVENUE DEDICATED STATE
OBLIGATION CONSIDERABLE AND ARE
COUNTY LOSING HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY YEAR
WHEN ALL SCHOOLS MAKE COUNTY
TURN BASICALLY. ANY THUNDER
ALREADY BUDGETED FOR IMPORTANT
LOCAL PUBLIC SERVICES. WITHOUT
REMOVING ONE THE TRAILER BILL
GOES BACK ON PREVIOUS
COMMITMENTS THE C. ENACTED INTO
LAW REGARDING THIS SORT OF DEAL
HAPPENING. AND TAKES AWAY
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FROM OUR COUNTY BUDGET OUR
EMPLOYEE AND A CRITICAL PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH SERVICES THE.
COUNTY PROVIDES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU HAVE CALLER.
HELLO I'M TRYING ELEVEN OPEN GO
AHEAD- YES MONEY WITHIN THE LONG
BALL WITH THE L. M. STRIVE.
TODAY I WORK WITH THE L. OF
SKEWS ME TO GROW A LOT OF THEM
THE- YOU CAN CHANGE OF COMMERCE
. WE DON'T BACK CHAMBERS MENTAL
BUT I'VE BEEN LITTLE BIT KERN
COUNTY BY CHANCE. CALIFORNIANS
ABOUT PRESS GEORGE THAT BECAUSE
BLACK AND ONE OF THE BALLOT
BLACK AND. WE'RE WE'VE RECENTLY
GOT A LETTER. OF THIS BOOK WEEK
THE TELL. PRIVATE AGENCY. WE
WANT TO. SUPPORT THE APPROVED OF
THEIR- OF ISSUE. BUT WE ALSO THE
- TO APPROVE TRAILER NINE.
ANYTHING THAT DEBT TO ADOPT
PRIVATE REGULATIONS FROM JULY
ONE. ANYWAY TO DANIEL ONE TWENTY
FOUR THREE AND THEN IN FROM JULY
ONE THREE TO JANUARY ONE TWENTY
FOUR. THIS WILL ALLOW THE AGENCY
TO MEET THE STATUTORY MANDATORY
AND MAINTAIN THE OF GOLD BUT
GOLD HEALTH PROBLEMS ISN'T
TWENTY FOUR. THEY DID EXPRESS
CONCERNS ABOUT MEETING THEIR
DEADLINES. AND WE DON'T THINK
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
REACH THAT. FOUR LEVEL FOR
STATUTORY DEADLINE BUT WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT THE FOLLOWING
THING AND DOUG FREE RULE MAKING
HEARINGS REACHING OUT TO DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES BOB VANDER
REGULATORY IMPACT ASSESSMENT TO
DETERMINE FINANCIAL IMPACT THE
PRICE WOULD BE REGULATION ON
SMALL DIVERSE BUSINESSES. THANK
AMEND FORMAL RULEMAKING SO ARE
WE ORGANIZATIONS CAN COMMENT ON
REGULATED. THAT'S JUST WORKABLE
RULE. LET ME GO WITH THE- IT IS
THE APPROACH OF A WHILE FLYING
NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH INSTEAD
WE RECOMMEND THE APPROACH OF
BUILDING A PLAN RIGHT THEY CAN
LAND SAFELY IN CALIFORNIA
ELIMINATING THE REYES AND THE
NECESSARY ASSOCIATED WITH
INNOVATING WHILE BREAKING AND
FIRST OF THE NATION REGULATORY
ACTION ON THE FLY. WITH THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
APPROVED THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE GIVE THE AGENCY MORE
TIME TO DEVELOP THE REGULATION
AND MORE TIME TO ENFORCE THEM AT
THE REGULATION IS ADOPTED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MY WRITER NEXT
CALLER. TOTALING THIRTY FOR YOU
AND THE HEAD- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS UNLESS IT'S
ALL HIGH ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BELMONT REDWOOD CITY AFTER
CITY AND THE TOWN IS STILL THROW
YOU CAN DAY REGARDING ISSUE
FORTY FIVE IRAQ BACK BELT. THE
LOCAL AGENT HERE'S MY FOR
CORRECTLY OPPOSED A MONTH AND
THEN IT AND I'M COMPOSED THIS
YEAR WHAT'S WORTH ANYTHING
COUNTIES OUR OWN LOCAL TAX
REVENUES PAY THE STATE INLAND
VEHICLE LICENSE FEE OBLIGATION
WITH RESULTANT DAMAGE YEAH
COUNTY AT THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR YOUR ONE
OFF CALLED THE COUNTY TRANBY
EIGHT. DECEMBER RD BUDGET BY
USING YOUR IDEAS TO FIND AT THE
TOP OF OR THAT OUR COMMUNITY I
CRY OF THE MINUTE THE IN AND
MARK FIELDS IN MAY I THINK OKAY
OCCURRED AT THE STATE OF THE
BURKE EIGHT. OBLIGATION IS ABLE
JOURNEY AND YOUR- AGUIAR-CURRY
THANK YOU. OUR WEL I'M PUT NINE
LINE IS OPEN IF I. THANK YOU MAN
CHAIRMAN JEFF NEAL WITH THE CAL
STATE AS THE OF COUNTIES- ALSO
SPEAK ABOUT THE AG HERE BELOW WE
SHOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
IMPROVEMENTS CONTINUE OKAY
PROVIDED IN THE GROUP BUT WE
ALSO HAVE TO OPPOSE. THE PEACE
THAT WE SOME. AND CITY TO FOR GO
. FOR THE STAGE WITH CREDIT CARD
AND- EARLY TO PAY. OKAY BODY IS
ALL VERY AS A THE MAJOR THAT
YOUR QUESTION ON THE THAT THIS
IS WHAT IT IS. TWO THOUSAND THE
STATE CUT THE PROPERTY ON CALL-
THAT WAY. A BIG REVENUES THAT
MANY WILL GO EACH- AND SO. BUT
IT WOULDN'T BE FAIR JUST COPY
CAR TAX AND HAVE EVERYTHING THEY
NEED ONLY BE OUT A BUNCH OF
MONEY TO STATE THAT HAVE YOU.
THAT MONEY THAT WE STARTED
TRANSFERRING YOU THIS TO BENEFIT
STATE JOURNAL FUND IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN. AND HAVE KIDS TO SHOW
FROM YOU EVER IT'S GOING ON
TODAY THE ORDER CAN BE DOLLAR
PER YEAR. I'M JUST YOU BACK OF
MONEY AND THAT'LL BE OUT BERSANT
YOU FOR CUTTING THE TAX. AND NOW
IN A FEW COUNTY THE LOS DUE TO
DECLINE AND ALL AS WELL AS THE
IN FROM TAX. THERE'S ENOUGH
MONEY THAT NINETY SHARE TO COVER
THE WHOLE COST OF THE CAR TAX.
AND SO. I YOU KNOW. I THINK WE
FAILED SEE THERE'S A JAPANESE.
THAT BECAUSE OF BECAUSE- ALMOND
AND THE PROPERTY TAX CHANGE.
THAT THE STATE IS NOW. NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR REAR THE CAR TAX
CUTS AND SO WE WOULD- THAT'S WHY
WE'RE- TO THAT HE IT. THAT
BETTER DAYS WE DO. THE PATIENCE
COMMENT THEM TO GET TO ACROSS-
UNTIL WE- BUT REQUEST. OPPOSED
WEAPON ENDED AND OUTLINE IN THE
THAT WE- A YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. RURAL AND
FORTY TWO ZERO OPEN THE. I THANK
YOU MADAM AND MEMBERS TÍNH
CALLING INTO AND BE OF THE
IRVING AND CAL. SEVERAL COUNTY
WHERE THAT'S AND THE COUNTY
SANTA CLARA- ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SAID PROPOSED TRAILER BUILDING
WHERE. IT IS THAT IRAQ- AS
CENTER CARNEY ARE MENTIONED
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF THINGS OVER
THE YEARS AND- MATT WITH ADDED
PROPERTY TAX ALLOCATION AND IT
SEEMS LIKE AND THAT THE CURRENT-
POSITION IS THAT THE BLS WALKED
IS NO LONGER FUNCTIONING AS
INTENDED. IT'S NOT THE CASE ARE
WE ARE MANY BACK TO BEEN AROUND
LONG ENOUGH AND YOU KNOW HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS TO BE HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH THEM AND TALK WITH
THEM ABOUT THE VERY ISSUES. TO
ENSURE THAT- LOCAL AGENCIES ARE
REMAIN. AT A PHYSICALLY ON
HARMED BY ANY REDUCTION
REGRETTABLY WE DON'T AGREE AT
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
APPROPRIATELY ADDRESSES THAT
BURKE AND DAN- AND WE WOULD JOIN
AGAIN WITH HER COLLEAGUES. IN
URGING YOUR REJECTION OF THIS AT
THIS PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE UNLESS IT IS AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU CAR. NEXT
CALLER MODERATOR. THE LAND FORTY
UNITED OF PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE ACROSS THE
TRUCKEE IN OF ISSUE FOR TWO
THIRTY DOLLARS FOR CULTURE DOES
. THE TWENTY CALL THE CONSISTS
ACTUALLY WORKS THE LAW ART
COMMUNITY AND COLLABORATION THE
POWER TRUCKEE COMPLETE THE
CALPERS PUBLIC ART NOT PLAN
COORDINATOR A SERIES OF WHAT ART
BEST. HIGHLIGHTED LOCAL ARTISTS
THROUGHOUT THE- SEASON TOOK FAN
TOUR AND THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
ARE NOT NO DEPENDENT ON THE
REGION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MARTIN IT'S COLOR. BROUGH AND
SIX NINE OF THE AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ON GOING TO FRIENDS
CEO THE BACK CHAMBERS COMMERCE-
EARLIER WE SENT YOU THIS ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT THEN WE SEND YOU A
LETTER. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
REGARDING CALIFORNIA PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS BUDGET. ARM
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE APPROVED THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND EXPAND
THE AGENCY'S STATUTORY DEADLINE
THE GENERAL ONE POINT TWENTY
THREE AND IT. WAS GOOD DAY THE
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY FOUR-
WE FEEL THAT THE- THANK YOU THEY
SAMPLED DIFFERENT AND SHOULD
CONDUCT PRE WILL. HEARING AND
OUTREACH TO DIVERSE COMMUNITY.
AND OF COURSE WHILE STANDARDIZED
REGULATORY IMPACT ASSESSMENT
UPON OUR SMALL AND DIVERSE
BUSINESSES AND COMMENCED FORMAL
RULEMAKING SO OUR ORGANIZATION
OUR DIVERSE POPULATION IN COMMON
OUR REGULAR REGULATION AND TO
GET. WORKABLE WORLDS FOR THAT-
WITHOUT RESPECT TO REQUEST.
APPROVAL OF THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ACT TO GIVE THE AGENCY
MORE TIME TO DEVELOP THE
REGULATION AND MORE TIME TO
ENFORCE THEM AFTER THE
REGULATIONS ADOPTED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU MARNIX
COLOR. BERLIN FORTY FOUR LENOVO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LORN AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
THE LANCASTER MUSEUM OF PUBLIC
ART FOUNDATION WITHIN THE BALL
OF OUR CULTURAL DISTRICT. A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS COALITION
SPEAKING. ACTORS NUMBER FORTY
ONE THE BALL OF OUR CULTURAL
DISTRICT OF BROADBAND THING ON.
LOCATED ON BANKRUPT BURKE WOULD
HAVE BEEN ME AT THE CENTER OF
CORE. MEMORIES OF FIGHT IN. YOU
FAT COMING OUT BUT NOW YOU'RE
ACTUALLY OUT SO I DON'T KNOW IF
BECAUSE WE CANNOT HEAR YOU- BUT
WE CERTAINLY HEARD THAT YOU
CALLED IN TO SUPPORT- THE ITEM
NUMBER. SO DO YOU. DO YOU FEEL
LIKE YOU GOT WHAT YOU NEEDED TO
SAY OUT ON THE RECORD. YES I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADD ONE
THING- RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL AND THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS WHICH- ARE IN
SUPPORT OF HIGHLIGHTING BE A
DIVERSE. DIVERSITY. OF THE STATE
I. PART OF BUDGET REQUEST ISSUE
. THANK YOU FOR HOLDING.
APOLOGIES YOU DON'T OKAY
MODERATOR THAT'S BECAUSE. ZERO
NINE FIFTY TWO RELIABLE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GO AHEAD SIR MA'AM.
HELLO HELLO YOU'RE ON. OKAY HEAR
ME YES GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID WILL
I'M HERE REPRESENTING SOME OF
THE LOOKING AT THIS BECAUSE THE
LATINO CULTURAL DISTRICT A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. MOBILITY
THAT IS RESERVED FOR MOWING
CONTINUE THE OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEAR LIKE YEAH YOU KNOW IT'S AN
AFTERMARKET COMMUNITY AND ASKED
THAT THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM HAS ENORMOUS
POTENTIAL THIS BUDGET WE
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE GOVERNOR
NUISANCE REQUEST THAT THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED THE USE
ALLIANCE ABOUT SUPPORTING THE
EXISTING FOURTEEN CULTURAL
DISTRICT AND ALSO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT THE MANY
AND VARIED CULTURAL COMMUNITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA ARE
REPRESENTED. WILL MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT PROGRAM-
IMPACTFUL THE FUNDING OF THE
PROGRAM WILL FOCUS EXPENDITURES
ON IDENTIFIED IN APPROVED LOCAL
NEEDS OF THE DISTRICT OF YOUR
COMMUNITY WHETHER THAT BE FOR
ARTIST DEVELOPMENT AND I'M A
DEVELOPMENT OR COMMUNITY PROGRAM
PROGRAMMING TO NAME A FEW AS
RECOGNIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS HIGHLIGHT CULTURAL
LEGACY OF OUR STATE'S MOST
VALUABLE RESOURCES ADVERSITY
FROM LARGE URBAN AREAS ARTICLE
RURAL LOCATION EACH DISTRICT
HELPS GROW SUSTAIN AUTHENTIC
ARTICLE OPPORTUNITIES. INCREASE
THE VISIBILITY OF LOCAL ARTISTS
AND PROMOTE SOCIOECONOMIC AND
ETHNIC DIVERSITY YOUR CULTURE
AND CREATIVE EXPRESSION WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY WRITER
NEXT CALLER. RIGHT THIRTEEN
UNITED OPEN GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
THAT OF THE MATTER NOT HOUSE OF
AFFAIRS- HI ON BEHALF OF
GREENLIGHTING I'M CALLING ISSUES
TEAM- THEY GOT LOCKED AGENCY
WORKS WITH FIFTY AND- TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE ON THE CHEAP
OFFICER I JUST GOT FROM THE
DRESSING EQUITY WITHIN A
GOVERNMENT HIRING AND
CONTRACTING PRACTICES. HOWEVER
DROPPING A RECALLS A STRUCTURAL
RACISM ACROSS THEIR LIVES IN
GOVERNMENT DEMANDS AND MEETING
ALL THE TRONG CRAFT AGENCY
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND STRATEGY
ANCHORED BY AN OFFICE THAT
TURNED- EQUITY COMMITMENT AND
ACTION ALL ACTIONABLE EQUITY AND
WE'RE REQUESTING ALLEGE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR. THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
EQUITY OFFICER TO STOP OR MAKE
PLAN IN INSTITUTIONALIZED
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIES FOR
DISMANTLING RACISM ACROSS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS- AND
EVERYTHING AFTER THE INCLUSION
IS AN IMPORTANT FUTURE EQUITY
BACK WE'VE GOT MORE MUST BE
DONE. CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
CYLINDER THAT PASSED BY
CREATING. A VALUE ENSURE THE.
FUTURE OF THE INTEGRITY. AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR- THANK YOU. NEXT WELL I
THIRTY OR IS OPEN THIS CALL.
THANK YOU KAREN MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS DAVE GRIFFIN AND I'M HERE
BEFORE YOU AS THE KERR CHAIR THE
UP ON COUNTY OF SUPERVISORS. I
ONLY TO SAY TO YOU AND ONE WEEK.
ON REQUEST REGARDING ACCESS THE
ROUTE. FIRST OFFERING AGREED TO
BECOME LETTER YOU RECEIVED ON
BEHALF OF THESE. USE THE STATE
RTE. EL CITIES THE COUNTY IS
THAT SANTA CLARA. SECONDLY
ELSEWHERE DEPARTMENT PLANS STAFF
OF COMMENTED TO THE EXTENT THE
RAP ONLY A CRUISE IN SOME OF THE
WEALTHIEST AREAS OF THE STATE.
THAT'S SIMPLY FALL. OPENING
COUNTY HAS BEEN ENTITLED TO
ACCESS THE RAP FOR YEARS DESPITE
BEING A LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
WITH APPROXIMATELY 35% OF OUR
POPULATION BEING NATIVE
AMERICAN. AND ABOVE 50% OF OUR
PRIMARY SCHOOL STUDENTS BEING
NATIVE AMERICAN WE ARE NOT
WEALTHY. LAST THE DEPARTMENT.
WRONGLY DENIED HER APPLICATION
CORRECTIVE THE RAP FOR THE
FISCAL YEARS 201-617-2017
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. YOU TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE TWO LETTERS
REQUESTING THE FNDS RATHER THAN
THE ONE BY REQUIRED PROOF
PREVIOUSLY AND PERSONNEL
TURNOVER IN OUR FINANCE
DEPARTMENT. WE MISSED THE NEED
FOR A SECOND LETTER IMAM
QUESTION IS THREE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN DOLLARS. WHICH IS
A LOT OF MONEY FOR A SMALL
COUNTY SUCH AS ALPINE. ALPINE
COUNTY IS REQUESTING. THAT ANY
CHANGE TO THE LEGISLATION. THE
REFORM THOSE THREE HUNDRED
NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN DOLLARS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. AND
CAN YOU GIVE ME A- TIME.
MODERATOR HOW MANY MORE ON THE
LINE. NINETEEN MAR. OKAY I'M
GONNA START HIT MISS AND WE'RE
GONNA STOP YOU AT ONE MINUTE.
ALL RIGHT NEXT CAR RURAL AND
FIFTY ONE FIFTY- AND IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KILL ROBINSON
ON BEHALF OF COMMENTING ON THE
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE ON IT SHE
EQUITY OFF THEIR APPLYING OUR
COMMENTS BUT THE GREEN LINE
DISTRIBUTE MAJOR BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING ADOBE HAPPY
WHILE UNILEVER ALSO SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATURE OUT ALLOCATING
ADDITIONAL FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO ESTABLISH A NEW OFFICE OF
RACIAL EQUITY. WHILE WE ARE
PLEASED WITH EVEN MINISTRATION
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER AT THE
BIRDS THAT I KNEW OFFICE OF
RACIAL EQUITY IS CRITICAL TO IT
APPLE CROP AGENCY EQUITY MARKET
STRATEGY. THANK YOU THANK. YOU
MARINERS CAR. BERLIN FIFTY THREE
YEAR VOTE THIS BY HAD. THANK YOU
THIS IS TO GROW ON THE DIRECTOR
OF THE PEDRO WATERFRONT ARTS
DISTRICT ONE OF FIVE
COLLABORATING PARTNERS AND THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS WE
ARE ALSO A PART OF THE ORIGINAL
FOURTEEN COHORT. IN THE
ADDITIONAL- PILOT PROGRAM AND
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF MORE
FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA COASTAL
DISTRICT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR. NEXT CALLER NINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BORN BACK
ON THE CARE OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
CALLING AND I DON'T TWENTY ONE
ENGINE YOU EXT EXPRESSED EXTREME
GRATITUDE TO THE LEGISLATURE BUT
UNWAVERING SUPPORT ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
THOUSAND GIRLS. RECENTLY
ALLOCATED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
TO LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS IN LA
CENTRAL VALLEY THE REAL
COMMUNITIES AND A GEOGRAPHICALLY
DIVERSE SET OF THE STATE THEY
REALLY NEED THE NEEDS OF WOMEN
AND GIRLS DURING HOLDEN AND AS
THEY RECOVER COMING OUT I'LL
MAKE IT QUICK BUT I JUST WANTED
SIX AND EXTREME GRATITUDE TO THE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR UNWAVERING
SUPPORT IN OUR EFFORTS. AND OUR
STAFF WILL BE REACHING OUT WITH
OUR ANNUAL REPORT ANSWERED BY
EITHER YOU ARE- GRANTING
CEREMONY ON MARCH FIFTEENTH
THANK YOU FOR THE TIMEAND HAVE
AN EXCELLENT DAY THANK YOUR.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. NINE FORTY
NINE ALIGNMENT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HEY THANK YOU MANAGER AND NEXT
LEVEL BEHALF OF GOT CALIFORNIA
AB- ADDING ON TO MY COLLEAGUES
FROM THE COUNTY AND THE CITY.
ARE YOU IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
LOOK CAREFULLY AT IMAGINATION
PROPOSAL AND IF YOU DON'T COUNTY
IMPACT THEY WILL HAVE ON CITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. MARIN NEXT
. BERLIN ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
ACTUALLY JERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS PETER COMISKEY
REPRESENTING THE BALBOA PARK
CULTURAL DISTRICT IN DENVER
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS
COALITION SUPPORTING ITEM FORTY
TWO CRUCIAL SUPPORT FOR CULTURAL
DISTRICT. THE CULTURAL DISTRICTS
WITHIN BROUGH PARK IS A UNIQUE
AREA DENSELY PACKED WITH
NONPROFIT ARTS SCIENCE HISTORY
AND CULTURAL INNOVATIONS. OUT OF
THE STORY BUILDINGS AND GOT. YOU
A LITTLE HERE AS A COUPLE CALLED
DISTRICTS AS A NORM POTENTIAL
SENTENTIAL COMES FROM
CELEBRATING THE EXISTING
DISTRICTS WITH ORGANIZATIONAL
SUPPORT. FINDING SUPPORT AND
FUNDING ALLOCATED SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE PLATES. DEVELOPED BY THE
CULTURAL DISTRICTS THEMSELVES.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY GROWING THE
PROGRAM TO TRULY REPRESENT THE
RICH CULTURAL TAPESTRY OF
CALIFORNIA. BEIJING FOREIGN ON
BEHALF OF THE FORTY MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURE DISTRICTS
COALITION I KNOW THEY ARE ALL
KEEN TO REFLECT AND CELEBRATE
THE UNIQUE NATURE ADDITION BOTH
WITH EACH OTHER AND TO OFFER
THEMSELVES AS METALS FOR
CULTURAL GROUPS IN THE
COMMUNITY. TO MAKE WISH TO
BECOME CULTURAL DISTRICTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. BRIAN FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ONLY IN FRENCH MARIA WITH
MATCHING CALIFORNIA CALLING ON
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE REGARDING THE
GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS AGENCY
WE'RE PLEASED TO SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ON SHE'S ON THE TWO
THAT WOULD BE AWESOME- THE STEP
TOWARD. ADDRESSING EQUITY WITHIN
STATE GOVERNMENT HIRING AND
CONTRACTING PRACTICES HOWEVER
THE ROOT CAUSES OF STRUCTURAL
RACISM ACROSS OUR LAWS AND
GOVERNMENT DEMAND THAT WE
DEVELOP A STRONG CROSS AGENCY
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND STRATEGY.
WE WERE CUT THE LEGISLATURE OUT
OF ALLOCATE FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CREATION OF
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY AND
COLOR COLLABORATION WITH THE
CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER THIS OFFICE
WILL COORDINATE PLAN
INSTITUTIONALIZED CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES FOR DISMANTLING
RACISM ACROSS STATE AGENCIES THE
DEPARTMENT. ADVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION IS IMPORTANT PIECE
TOWARDS EQUITY BUT MORE MUST BE
DONE EQUITY CAN NO LONGER BE AN
AFTERTHOUGHT THE STATE'S
PROGRAMMATIC AND POLICY WORK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
RIGHT FIVE ATLANTA OPEN GO AHEAD
. THE NEW MY AND SHE MEMBERS
PERFORMED YOU OF CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA AREN'T
ADVOCATES ON A HUGE NINETEEN
FORTY KILLED IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INVESTMENT IN
ARTS AND CULTURE. INCLUDING
THIRTY MILLION A CULTURAL
DISTRICTS PROGRAM WITH HER FROM
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY HOW IMPORTANT THE ARTS ARE
INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES AND HOW
REMAIN UNDERFUNDED- WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER INCREASING
THE BASE PLAN FUNDING FOR THE-
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE DEEPER
INVESTMENT IN THEIR ONGOING
PROGRAMS BY LOCAL. ALL DISTRICTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN ADDITION TO
THE CULTURAL DISTRICTS PROGRAM
THE THINKING BEHIND BUDGET HAS
NOT INCREASED IN THREE YEARS HAS
REMAINED TWENTY SIX MILLION OR
APPROXIMATELY POINT FIFTY SIX
CENTS PER PERSON CALIFORNIA WE
ASK LEGISLATURE TO CHAMPION ONE
DOLLAR ART IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. TWENTY THREE
BUDGET INCREASE IN GENERAL FUND
BEFORE THE CALIFORNIA ARE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR TWENTY SIX
MILLION TO FORTY MILLION OR ONE
DOLLAR PER CAPITA CAPITA PER
PERSON OVER THREE YEARS AT A
COST OF FORTY MILLION PER YEAR
FOR A TOTAL FORTY TWO MILLION.
BY PROVIDING AN INCREASE OF A
THREE YEAR SO I WANNA LET YOU
KNOW YOUR NAME AND BIRTH DATE OR
ANYTHING SO JUST OKAY. THIS IS
HAVE SECOND GENERATION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE OUR THRIVING
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK. YOU
MY WRITER NEXT CALLER. NICE TO
THE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALL BRENT HE WON HI CHRIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDICARE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JULIE KAPLAN AND I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE I'M CALLING IN
ON IF YOU THIRTY FIVE ABOUT
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AGENCY
MINDTAP TEAM FRIENDS THAT
CAPITAL COLLABORATIVE ON RACE
AND EQUITY OR CORE AND TREATED
SWEEPING DECEMBER FOURTEENTH
CALIFORNIA STATE AGENCIES
DEPARTMENT MISSION. IN
UNDERSTANDING INSTITUTIONAL
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND DEVELOPING
PLANS TO DRESS EVEN JUSTICES.
BURKE WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED BUDGET CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER AND WE ALSO REQUEST THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ADDRESS ALLOCATE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CREATION OF AN OFFICE AND RACIAL
EQUITY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
OFFICE WILL TAKE THIS WORK EVEN
FURTHER- FORTY THINK LIKE RACIAL
EQUITY IN BUDGETING PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT ALLOCATION
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIP THE WHOLE
DURING GAMES WHEN I'M MORE. IN
ADDITION TO THE VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE THAT DEVOPS AGENCY AROUND
WORKFORCE AND CONTRACTING
WITCHER SAID YES I CAN'T I'M
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NEXT HELLO FIFTY
EIGHT HE'S GLAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS LIZ JOHNSON ON THE TO OF
BRAND VISION FOUNDATION A IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUES TWO I A HALF
OF THE SAN HE GOT A CALL JUST
WHICH IS IN THE VIDEO LUCK AND-
WE ARE ALSO IN THE OF THE-
COASTAL DISTRICT. FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS WE WORKED HARD ON A
SHOESTRING BUDGET TO ESTABLISH
THE THANK YOU TO OUR DISTRICT
WHICH HAS HELPED US BELIEVE
REVISED ARE ONCE DYING DOWNTOWN
TODAY OUR WHOLE DISTRICT IS HOME
TO MANY ART STUDIO THEATRE THE
BATTLESHIP IN THE QUERY ON MANY
NON. ORGANIZATIONS AND MORE
THESE ACTIVITIES PROVIDE JOBS
FOR EXAMPLE I RUN AN ARTS
ORGANIZATION IN THE DISTRICT
THAT INVOICE FIFTEEN ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE CREATIVE PEOPLE OUR
BUSINESS IS NOT STRUGGLE DURING
THE PANDEMIC WITH MANY CLOSING
THEIR DOORS ARE YOU CAN
PERFORMING ARTS BEFORE
ESPECIALLY HARD HIT WE SUPPORT
THE FUNDING REQUEST FOR THAT
MANY COMMUNITIES SUCH AS OURS IN
FACT THERE ARE DISTINCT
DISTRICTS AND THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOUR MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE GO TO LINE AND
- THESE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY CHARM I'D LIKE THAT HERE HERE
HOW GROWTH PROBABLY NEVADA CITY
COUNCIL DISTRICT AND PARTY
BECAUSE FOR THE FOR PARTNERS
REQUEST COMMITTEE. OFFER BEFORE
BECAUSE USED BUDGET FOR THE OUT
INCLUDING THIRTY MILLION ONE
FIVE FUNDING SUPPORT EXPAND THE
CALIFORNIA DOES PROGRAM. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS APPROACH IS
ONE OF THE STATE SIX AFTER I
THANK SENATE WILL DRIVE A COUPLE
WE ARE AND THE DYNAMIC. WHAT IS.
A INCOME DIVIDE TOURISM OR
BUSINESS MORE FOLKS. YES READY
THE- WHAT OF THE PROGRAMS THAT.
IF IT WERE HIGH BETWEEN UNITS
THE GULF BUSINESS THAT SAYS ON
THE CREASE. OF THIS PROVIDES A
HIGH ACCOUNTABLE. PUBLIC AND-
THAT TO REFORM TO A BROADER OF
OPPORTUNITY. MUCH FUNDING
INNOVATION AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
. RIGHT WHAT THAT COULD. I DON'T
THINK THAT WOULD MAKE HOW SO I
KNOW YOU PACKING MANY SO HOPING
THAT YOU WERE UP. THANK YOU FOR
POINTING OFF ON THE REPRESENTS.
AND INCOMES CULTURAL HERITAGE IS
VITAL AN UPDATE OF THE NATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
SUPPORT HERITAGE THE PHONES ARE
VERY MAKE UP OF OUR REGION.
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING THE
PROPOSAL. KERN MODERATOR NEXT
CALL. NEXT TO LINE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU'RE TALKING
AND TRANSPARENT MANY NUMBER OF
MY NAME IS ROBERT INTERLINE
REPRESENTING THE LINE HOUSING OF
OUR HISTORY AND OF OUR CULTURAL
DISTRICT A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS
COLLISION URGING YOU CAN ACQUIRE
ITEM FORTY TWO ARTICLE OR
CULTURAL DISTRICT IS LOCATED IN
MY HOUSE OF THE TRIBAL HOMELAND
OF THE- YOUNG MAN YOUR MAN COULD
KIND OF LIKE PEOPLE. OF THAT
COALITION ARGUMENT STARK
ORGANIZATION BUT I'M CONFIDENT
THAT BOTH OF OUR CULTURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROVED TO BE A
VITAL FRAMEWORK AN ORGANIZING
TOOL FOR ALL THE GOVERNMENT AND
THEN I KNOW REGION THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AFTER A- COUPLE OF OUR
CULTURAL DISTRICT WELL AS THE
THIRTEEN OTHER DIFFICULT THANK
NEEDED NORTH OF THE FOR SURE
ABOUT THE MANY AND VARIED
CULTURAL COMMUNITIES OF THE FACT
WITH IN CALIFORNIA. OF ALL
REPRESENTED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OPERATOR. NEXT CALL. NAY WHO
A LINE SIX FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT AFTER MATTER CHAIRMAN THEN
PLEASE PREVENT THE TO REPRESENT
CARLA MARC PARK OFFICE IN LOS
ANGELES. I'M CALLING IN ON ISSUE
THIRTY FIVE REGARDING THE CHIEF
EQUITY OFFICER WERE ALIGNED WITH
PREVIOUS COMMENTS MADE IN
SUPPORT OF A FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
CHIEF AND COULD BE OFFERED THERE
THE OFFICE WILL COORDINATE PLAN
AND INSTITUTIONALIZED OUR STATE
STRATEGIES MANTLING RACISM
ACROSS STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. OFFICE CONFIRMED
THAT THE VEHICLE OPERATIONALIZE
RACIAL JUSTICE FOR GOVERNMENT
SYSTEM ENSURING THAT COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR MOST IMPACTED BY
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND THE
PANDEMIC RECEIVED A MAXIMUM
BENEFIT OF GOVERNMENT RESOURCES
INCLUDING HISTORIC FUNDING
INVESTMENT COMING TO OUR STATE
THROUGH FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND
OUR STATE BUDGET SURPLUS. WE
URGE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FORTY
MILLION FOR THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY AND ENSURE WE CAN
ERADICATE STRUCTURAL RACISM IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK YOU
. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MORE ON
THE LINE. ONE MOMENT. THERE'S
TEN MORE OKAY. READY. I KNOW WHO
THE TO LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM A
FRIENDLY I WORK WITH ABOUT THE
PROJECT CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING IN ON ISSUE THIRTY FIVE
REGARDING THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER ACTUALLY PREVIOUS
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT MINISTRATION
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- BUT SHE
EXACT EQUITY OFFICE THERE. ARE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ADDRESSING EQUITY WITHIN. EIGHT GOVERNMENT HIRING AND
CONTRACTING PRACTICE. DEVELOPING
A STRONG COFFEE EQUITY GRAMMAR.
I STRATEGY IN BY ALL.
TRANSACTION TO EQUITY. INTO
ACTIONABLE STRATEGIES IF HE SAID
SOMETHING THE ROOT CAUSES OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM. WE ALSO
REQUEST LEGISLATOR. ALLOCATE
FORTY MILLION TO ESTABLISHED
OFFICE OF WHICH IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE CHIEF EQUITY OFFICER
THEIR OFFICE WILL COORDINATE ON
AND INSTITUTIONALIZED CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES FOR THIS MONTH ONLY
FROM ACROSS STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. MY WRITER NEXT CALLER
. NINE NINE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS GERMAN BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION- CALIFORNIA I'M
CALLING TODAY IN REGARDS ISSUE
THIRTY FIVE- WE ARE DELIGHTED TO
BE THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ON
CREATING THE CHIEF EQUITY
OFFICER THIS IS NO DOUBT A
POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT. HOWEVER WE
CAN KIND OF DRAFTING STRUCTURAL
RACISM TO ENSURE THAT THE
DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE
SERVICEMEN EQUITABLE- WILL
REQUIRE PAIN HOLISTIC AND
STRATEGIC APPROACH THAT CUTS
ACROSS. ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. THEREFORE WE DO
SUPPORT WITH OUR COLLEAGUE AND
REQUESTING COLLECTED. ALLOCATE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CREATION OF AN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. FOR THOSE WHO LINE
UP FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON BUT AND THEN- SENATE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MONICA THE
CHIEF OPERATION OFFICER I MEAN
SHE DOES DECIDE. CALIFORNIA MAIN
STREET AND A MEMBER OF THE
EXECUTIVE TEAM MOBILE CYCLE TO
DISTRICT WHICH ON A PERCENTAGE
DAY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ASIAN REPORTED TO KEEP
ALLOCATION OF THE CULTURE
DISTRICT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR
EFFORTS AND CONTINUE PROMOTE
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY ARGUED
WITH- AND THE RIVAL OF MANY
SECTORS WHICH INCLUDES RESIDENTS
BUSINESSES COMMUNITY- GOVERNMENT
AND ALSO- PARTNERS OUTSIDE OF
OUR DISTRICTS SO WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO
KEEP GROWING AND KEEP OUR
RECOVERY EFFORTS STRONG AND THAT
WE- LEAD TO HIGHLIGHTING FEATURE
ARE CULTURAL. AND OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH SURROUNDS THE
DOWNTOWN- OF OUR OF OUR DISTRICT
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY WRITER
NEXT CALLER. THANK HELLO SEVENTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER
THAT ENSURING MEMBER- GOTTEN
HERE THE HEALTH I WANTED TO
STATE MEETING AT ADDED OKAY I'M
CALLING IN ON A THIRTY RELATING
TO GOVERNOR OPERATE EIGHT EIGHT.
NINE PREVIOUS COM HERE'S I THAT
YOUR BUDGET COMMITTEE ALLOCATE
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS THE FUNNY
THOUGHTLESSNESS WHY OFFICE
COOLEY PLEASE GIVE ME MINISTRY
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TYPICALLY
OFFICER AND THAT PROGRESS EQUITY
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT HIRING
AND CONTRACTING PRACTICES
HOWEVER ADDRESSING THE ROOT
CAUSES STRUCTURAL RACISM ACROSS
OUR LAWS AND GOVERNMENT DEMANDS
THAT WE DEVELOP STRONG CROSS
AGENCY EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND
STRATEGY. ANGERED BY AN OFFICE
THAT TURNED OUR EQUITY
COMMITMENT INTO ACTIONABLE
EQUITY STRATEGY THE HOSPITAL
DENTAL LIFE COORDINATE PLAN
INSTITUTIONALIZED CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES FOR DISMANTLING
RACISM ACROSS STATE PARK. THE
EQUITY AND INCLUSION IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE TOWARD EQUITY
BUT MORE MUST BE DONE AGAIN WE
KINDLY REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE
ALLOCATE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE CREATION OF THE PROFITS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. GO TO LINE THE
SEVEN PLEASE CLASS. HELLO ALL
RIGHT YOUR MIND OPEN. ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON. I'LL CALL BACK
LINE SEVENTY NINE THE LION.
HELLO SHURMUR'S- RYAN GREGORY
HERE CHAIR THE NAPA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS CALLING IN
REGARDS TO ISSUE FORTY FIVE- WE
LIKE TO- CONVEY OUR MY BORDERS
MY BOARDS- UNANIMOUS OPPOSITION
TO THE CURRENT ERA BACK FILLED
TRAILER FOR ALL THE REASONS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY SPOKEN
TO BUT JUST SO YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR NOW- IF THAT
REPRESENT THE KIND OF ABOUT 10%
OF OUR GENERAL FUND EVERY YEAR
WERE SMALL COUNTY THAT WILL BE
HARD TO ABSORB. COLLECTIVELY
ABOUT FORTY MILLION FOR OUR
ENTIRE COUNTY CLEANER CITY- THE
DEADLINE WE'RE WE'RE STILL
SPENDING MONEY ON HOLDEN AND
RECOVERING FROM OUR THREE RECENT
WILDFIRES AND- THE NEXT ONE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THAT- WE DO THINK
AFFECT THIS WARRANTED BUT- IT
DOES ONE NEED A LOT MORE WORK TO
GET IT RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU HONOR IT- NEXT CALLER
. AND A FULL LINE EIGHTY. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RICARDO IDEAS- DAY
DIRECTOR AT THE LOCAL PAYMENT
PRACTICES BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW
CULTURAL HERITAGE DISTRICT
CALLING TO SUPPORT EMPLOYEE TO
FUNDING FOR CULTURE DISTRICTS AS
WELL AS THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY. WE ARE PROUD TO BE AMONG
THE INITIAL COHORT OF
CALIFORNIANS CONTRA
DISFIGUREMENT HOPING THAT THE
DESIGNATION THAT AWB INCLUDING
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR A
GRASSROOTS WORK WE'RE DOING ON
THE GROUND WHICH IS- AND LIKE HE
DID NOT TRANSPIRED BECAUSE A
PANDEMIC. OUR CULTURE DISTRICT
AND COMMUNITY WITH HIT VERY HARD
WITH A PANDEMIC WITH MANY OF OUR
RESIDENTS AND ARTISTS USING
THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND WE NOW LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY ASIDE
FROM THE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
AND OUTSIDE STATEMENT WHERE.
SOME OF THE FINANCES ALSO BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THANK YOU
PROVISIONAL EQUITY IN THE ARTS
AND NOTHING SYSTEMIC RACISM
HAPPENS DISCO WE AFFECTED WITH
THE THERE YOU KNOW BECAUSE IF
YOU LOOK UP I IT'S GOING CONTROL
. FOR OVER A HEALTH AND THAT'S
WELL. AT THE BOTTOM PUBLIC I
PACKAGE TO ECONOMIC GROWTH AND
THAT POINT I COMMUNITY STARTED
AND CULTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU MODERATOR. EXCO NEXT
WIL NINE EIGHT TWO BUT. GOOD
THANK YOU FOR ME ON SHOULD
DIRECTOR OF THE THAT THAT
READING IT DESIGNATE MAIN
ORGANISED ANTOINE THE FOUNDING
ORGANISER. THAT PUT THE OUR
DISTRICT LOVE. IN AND IN ONE AND
WEBER PART THE STATE REPORTER
CULTURE JUST TRY- AND WE LOVE
OUR CALL FOR THE AS- ONLY
BECAUSE IT PROVIDES GREAT DID.
BOARD CULTURAL AND SOCIALLY
WE'VE ALSO HAD GREAT. ECONOMIC
BENEFIT FROM AS WELL IT'S BEEN
TERRIFIC CATALYST- ARE
DESIGNATION CREATED THE
CONDITIONS AND COMMUNITY
AWARENESS. WE'RE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE RECOGNIZED THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
FREEDOM KRUGMAN. SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
BUSINESS THE FATHER GROUPEMENT
OUR NEW DOWNTOWN GALLERY HAD
OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
BAIL FOR LOCAL ARTISTS. AND WE
CURRENTLY RESIDE IN A HISTORIC
I- AT ALL THERE WOULD BE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN GRAND FORKS TO MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS- DURING THIS YEAR
WE ALSO SO I WILL LET YOU KNOW
YOUR AT YOUR BUILDING A PARKING
LOT IN. THE BALLPARK. ONE FIVE
MILLION IN. GREAT ECONOMIC POWER
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MODERATOR HOW MANY MORE IN THE
QUEUE. TWO MORE OKAY GREAT NEXT
CALL. THANKS WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY THREE THE BILL HAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS LESLIE
CASTELLANO AND I AM SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ISSUE NUMBER FORTY
TWO IN THE EUREKA ARTS AND
CULTURE DISTRICT- I'M AIRPORT
MEMBERS YOUR TO MAIN STREET THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE NJ
PEOPLE AND CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
FOR EUREKA. I'M HERE BECAUSE THE
ARTS AND CULTURE DISTRICT IN
EUREKA IS REALLY FUNDAMENTAL TO.
NOT ONLY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND- THE ARTS AND CULTURE AND
INHERENT WHO- M. AND OVERALL
WELL BEING BUT ALSO TO THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY
FOR PEOPLE TO COME TOGETHER AND
AS WE MOVE AWAY FROM THE-
PANDEMIC. THE LAST YEAR WE'VE
SEEN THE RISE OF THE YEAR TO
CHINATOWN PROJECT WHEN WE ARE
CULTURAL CENTER WITHIN ARGUE
CULTURE DISTRICT. AND I AM EVERY
DAY I'M IMPRESSED AMAZED BY THE
CLARITY AND PROFOUND CAPACITY
FOR COMMUNICATION THAT. POSSIBLE
THROUGH THIS DESIGNATION AND
IT'S- CRITICAL THAT IT'S FUNDED
BECAUSE THAT WILL HELP LEAD TO
THE DRIVING NOT ONLY OF THE
DISTRICT AS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
REPRESENTED AND EMPOWERED. THE
EXISTENCE OF THE DISTRICT. THANK
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. I LOVE TO
GO TO LINE A FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD HI MY NAME IS SUSAN PER
JAM I'M GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS I AM A MEMBER OF THE END
OF STATE AND- AID GROUPS THAT.
LIVE INDOORS SB SEVENTEEN WHICH
IS THE ADDRESSES ISSUES THIRTY
FIVE TODAY I BELIEVE VERY
STRONGLY IN OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY TO COORDINATE AND LEAD
THE STATE. STRATEGIES FOR
ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY ACROSS
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS THE
STATE MUST PLAY A MORE ACTIVE
DEDICATED STATEWIDE ROLE IN
DISMANTLING RACIAL INEQUITY AS
WE KNOW THIS WILL LEAD TO BETTER
OUTCOMES FOR ALL RESIDENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO STRUGGLE
TO RECEIVE EQUITABLEHEALTH
CARE. HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
DEPLOYMENT XCERRA ADDRESSING
THESE DISPARITIES CANNOT AND
WILL NOT HAPPEN BY ITSELF
REQUIRES A CONSCIOUSLY DESIGNED
MECHANISMS CERTIFIED CORRECT
EQUITIES FOR ERIC YOU AND
SUPPORT YOU TO ALLOCATE FORTY
NINE FOR THE CREATION OFFICE OF
RACIAL EQUITY. ANALYST FINISHES
SAYING THAT WE NEED STRATEGIES
FOR DISMANTLING RACISM ACROSS
STATE AGENCIES A LOT HAD ENSURE
BEST PRACTICES AND POLICIES THAT
VALUE DIVERSITY FAIRNESS AND
RIGHT RACIAL EQUITY AND SERVE AS
A NATIONAL MODEL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY. OTHERS CALLERS IN THE
QUEUE. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
YOU OKAY GREAT I HEARD FOR ALL
THE OF THE- SENATORS COME YOUR
OWN AND YOU HAVE ANY IDEA
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. SEEING
NONE THAT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE. IT UP INTO THREE
VOTES. SO DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR ISSUES
FOR ISSUES ONE. SIX THROUGH
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN THROUGH
NINETEEN AND. TWENTY TWO TO
THIRTY TWO OAKLAND- OKAY OKAY
MOVED BY SENATOR AT NIELSEN
PASSED SO. THEY'RE GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL. KAMLAGER I CABALLERO
NIELSEN RIGHT FIVE ALL RIGHT
THAT MOTION GETS OUT WITH FOUR
ZERO THAT ITEM THOSE ITEMS- ONE
SIX TO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN TO
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWO TO
THIRTY TWO I DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR ISSUES
ITEMS THREE THROUGH FIVE
FOURTEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE.
SO MOTION IS GET MOVED BY
SENATOR RON. PLEASE CALL THE
WORLD CENTERS KAMAGRA I
CABALLERO NIELSEN. ROXBURGH
EMOTION THOSE ITEMS GET OUT WITH
THREE ONE THREE ICE NO ONE. NOW
WE WILL MOVE ON TO A MOTION ON
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER TWO. CAN I HAVE A
MOTION. MORE MOVED BY SENATOR
CABALLERO THANK YOU CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AND
THERE'S A COMMA GIRLFRIEND
CABALLERO NIELSEN THING ROCK
FIVE. THAT ITEM GETS OUT WITH A
THREE ZERO THREE EYES ON IT OKAY
THAT IS IT- WE HAVE NO ITEMS ON
CALL THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE UNABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT THE WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION WE DO APPRECIATE
YOU YOUR TIME AND YOUR PATIENCE
AND YOUR COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. THE SENATE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE FOR IS
ADJOURNED.